pourquoi vraiment d'hollywood est née au
nigeria et pas par exemple au sénégal au
mali comme on est un homme d'affaires
ont déjà des hommes comme femmes tout le
monde et businessman et c'est assez
impressionnant donc nollywood est
clairement le vent en poupe et les
budgets ce qui est gros budgets des
films à gros budget comme aux états unis
même en france d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui le record de budget au
nigeria ces neuf millions de dollars et
monter en gamme
d'un point de vue technique au niveau
des histoires racontées etc
et du coup ça implique effectivement des
budgets beaucoup plus important donc il
ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent et
beaucoup de pays en afrique francophone
notamment qui regarde ce qu'est ce qu'on
ait jamais inquiets qu'ils apprennent et
qui essayent de
de faire pareil
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités en plateau et nos
reporters sur le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 20 janvier à double comité
d'accueil hostile pour emmanuel macron
le président en visite ce matin dans une
usine de dunkerque symbole de
l'attractivité française est en
représentation cet après midi à
versailles face à 200 patrons étrangers
deux rendez vous lors desquelles il a
été reçu par des manifestants opposés à
la réforme des retraites
en irak un nouvelle flambée de violence
trois manifestants ont été tués et des
dizaines de blessés lors d'affrontements
avec les forces de sécurité une escalade
de tension qui intervient à l'expiration
du délai donné au gouvernement par le
de contestation pour répondre à ses
revendications beyrouth toujours en
pleine déroute
réunion aujourd'hui autour du président
libanais des hauts responsables de la
sécurité
en cause un week-end de violences entre
manifestants antigouvernementaux et
forces de l'ordre bilan au moins 520
blessés
[Musique]
elle ne veut pas devenir une décharge
pour les pays développés la malaisie a
renvoyé 150 conteneurs de déchets
plastiques vers plusieurs pays dont 43
vers la france une décision qui suit des
celles déjà prises par l'indonésie et
les philippines alors que certaines
localités se retrouvent submergés par
les déchets le maintien de l'ordre dans
le collimateur de sa politique réclame
la démission du préfet de police de
paris après la diffusion de vidéos
montrant un policier frapper un
manifestant au sol en marge d'une
manifestation de gilet jaune
le ministre de l'intérieur demande lui
des explications le fonctionnaire de
police impliqué deux de ses collègues
ont porté plainte contre le manifestant
peut-on encore organiser des
manifestations sans débordement en
france peut-on manifester sans danger ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face à
21h30 ce soir
[Musique]
emmanuel macron et et à versailles cet
après midi pour le troisième sommet 12
french traduction choisi à la france
un rendez vous face à 200 patrons
d'entreprises internationales objectif
les inciter à investir dans l'hexagone
une réunion avec un comité d'accueil
hostile pour le chef de l'état puisque
de nombreux manifestants opposés à la
réforme des retraites sont présents
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines le point
sur place avec katia pique nique
pourquoi protesté t-il aujourd'hui
contre la réforme des retraites vous le
savez bien
mais également contre cette réunion tous
french organisé par le président
français cette réunion vise à attirer
les investisseurs étrangers
il y aura une série de rencontres
bilatérales entre emmanuel macron et des
dirigeants par exemple de youtube de
netflix ou encore general elektriks
d'autres réunion avec des ministres
et puis un dîner il se trouve que cette
réunion permettra emmanuel macron
d'annoncer certaines mesures comme par
exemple la mise à disposition de
territoires industriels avec des
procédures clés en main pour limiter les
démarches administratives qui sont
souvent très rebit en bus rebutante pour
les patrons qui souhaiteraient
s'installer et le président fera
également d'autres annonces concernant
le déménagement de sièges sociaux à
l'ère post ben brik site
il faut dire que cette réunion passe mal
aujourd'hui auprès des grévistes des
syndicalistes qui se bat depuis un mois
et demi un contre cette réforme des
retraites
cet événement qui va favoriser le
patronat passe en effet mal je vous
proposais d' écouter des grévistes que
nous avons interviewé ce matin ainsi que
le député eric coquerel de la france
insoumise c'est important puisque déjà
les mails et les manifestants sont là le
mouvement contre les retraites est là et
moi je me suis fait fort de les soutenir
le plus possible donc aujourd'hui c'est
ici que ça se passe et c'est ici que ça
se passe parce que monsieur macro moi
j'allais dire fait une provocation de
plus c'est à dire venir en pleine
mobilisation sociale d'une ampleur
historique avec les 200 plus grands
patrons se pavaner dans un lieu qui est
quand même symbolique d'un régime qui
est pas celui de la république terre à
versailles
bon je trouve ça je crois que parce
qu'ils se rendent compte à quel point
c'est ça une image assez insupportable
au reste du pays voilà il est avec ce
dont il fait profiter de ses largesses
et de sa politique depuis deux ans une
bio au détriment de du pays à force de
casser ce qui reste de l'état social à
force de faire des cadeaux fiscaux aux
plus riches
voilà c'est le résumé de maquereaux on
profite de l'occasion de la venue de
monsieur macro à versailles qui vient
par se réunir avec 200 patrons étrangers
pour faire la promotion de la france et
des investissements en france pour lui
rappeler que nous sommes toujours
opposés à la réforme des retraites
par ailleurs c'est aussi l'occasion de
mettre l'accent sur le fait que la
présidence est davantage tournée vers le
patronat que vers les salariés
on a vu que emmanuel macron était
recevez aujourd'hui les les 200 patrons
de france et puis quelques ministres
symboliquement versailles c'est quand
même je trouve que c'est encore une fois
un président qui nous fait un sacré pied
de nez en décidant d'aller à versailles
et encore une fois nous avons fait un
point sur la mobilisation avec les
syndicats à présent nombreux syndicats
des yvelines
ils nous ont dit que la mobilisation
continue et on sait que par exemple à la
ratp
la décision a été de suspendre la grève
mais les syndicalistes nous ont expliqué
que d'autres corps de métier avait
rejoint le mouvement comme par exemple
les avocats ou encore les raffineries
qui entre dans la danse
donc cette mobilisation se poursuit même
si c'est sous d'autres formes nous ont
infirmé ces syndicalistes et avant
d'accueillir à versailles les 210 j'en
entreprises étrangères emmanuel macron
s'est rendu ce matin à dunkerque
objectif visiter l'usiné
astrazeneca symbole de l'attractivité
médine france
le groupe biopharmaceutique
anglo-suédois annoncé hier 500 millions
d'euros d'investissements sur le
territoire hexagonal sur place une
cinquantaine de manifestants cgt une
dizaine d'avocats du barreau de
dunkerque sept manifestants ont
d'ailleurs été interpellés parmi eux un
avocat les précisions de nadège
abderrazak gilet jaune avocat et membre
de la cgt ont fait le déplacement ont
tenté en tout cas de s'approcher de ce
site pharmaceutique pour approcher
emmanuel macron et lui faire part de
leur opposition à la réforme des
retraites et ça a été
mission impossible pour ces manifestants
pourquoi et bien parce que le dispositif
autour de cette zone est complètement
bouclé un dispositif de sécurité
extrêmement important de nombreux
contrôles de véhicules et d'identité en
lieu je vous propose d'écouter deux des
manifestants déçus de ne pas avoir pu
approcher le chef de l'état nous avons
souhaité rencontrer effectivement
monsieur emmanuel macron ou ses proches
pour le sensibiliser à notre
interpellation
les avocats sont en grève depuis
maintenant 15 jours cette grève a été
reconduite de nouveau pendant une
semaine les avocats n'accepte pas la
réforme que l'on veut leur imposer en
termes de régimes de retraite il s'agit
en réalité est bien
d'une manifestation nationale et
l'ensemble des barreaux de france et de
navarre sont actuellement en grève pour
et bien faire pression pour le
gouvernement auprès du gouvernement pour
pouvoir être simplement entendus pour
faire valoir effectivement leurs
observations
les avocats sont présents ils défendent
un principe essentiel qui est la liberté
de manifester chose tout à fait
incompréhensible
l'un de nos confrères a été interpellé
sans avoir commis la moindre infraction
avec ses papiers d'identité et il a été
emmené sans aucun motif sans aucun motif
emmené au commissariat de grande synthe
et chose effrayante monsieur le
procureur de la république n'était même
pas informés de la mise en garde à vue
du confrère ce qui constitue en réalité
une irrégularités procédurales manifeste
il fallait qu'on soit là bien évidemment
pour accueillir le président des riches
et lui faire savoir
qu'on était totalement déterminée sur le
dunkerquois comme comme ailleurs dans le
pays pour obtenir le retrait de cette
réforme comprend bas depuis plusieurs
semaines du côté de la cgt on est
extrêmement déterminé on va continuer
toutes les formes d'actions y compris
par la grève pour pouvoir obtenir ce
qu'on veut donc le retrait du projet de
loi mais on est on est pas seule la cgt
le le front commun syndical est toujours
là mais donc il ya une majorité de
syndicats unis qui s'opposent au projet
de loi et qui vont continuer à
travailler des ddd mobilisation sous
toutes les formes et les avocats à
dunkerque mais également à paris
aujourd'hui les robes noires aux côtés
des gilet jaune pour manifester à
l'intérieur du tribunal de grande
instance de la capitale
une dizaine d'entre eux ont appelé
notamment la démission des menus m écran
ils dénoncent la réforme des retraites
du gouvernement est toujours après
l'acte 62 des gilet jaune émaillés de
heurts les violences nu ce que jamais
d'actualité
trois policiers dont l'auteur des coups
portent plainte contre les manifestants
molesté samedi à paris dans le même
temps une enquête judiciaire est ouverte
par l'igpn pour violences volontaires
par personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique selon le secrétaire général du
syndicat police alliance les militants
auraient proféré des propos haineux je
cite j'ai vu que j'ai le sida
tu vas crever fin de citation et le
gilet jaune christophe dettinger et va
devoir patienter pour savoir s'il pourra
toucher l'argent de sa cagnotte litchi
le tribunal judiciaire de paris a
ordonné cet après-midi la réouverture
des débats fixée au 19 mai le but
déterminer si cette récolte de fonds
porte atteinte à l'ordre public
l'ex boxeur condamné à un an de prison
pour avoir frappé des gendarmes lors de
l'acte 8d gilet jaune espère percevoir
l'argent de cette cagnotte qui lui avait
été suspendu par la plate forme de
collecte en ligne
et alors que la france vit son quarante
septième jour de grève contre la réforme
des retraites les internes en médecine
se mobilisent
eux aussi à l'appel des syndicats
rassemblement aujourd'hui encore à paris
place du panthéon horaire hebdomadaire
conséquent repos de sécurité bafoués ou
encore des choix de stages anxiogène les
revendications sont nombreuses les
précisions sur place avec estelle fages
ils sont plusieurs dizaines à être
rassemblés ici à place du panthéon où je
me trouve c'est la troisième journée de
mobilisation pour les ans les internes
qui sont en grève illimitée depuis le 10
décembre ea dernier un rassemblement à
l'appel de l'intersyndicale nationale
des internes de france
et justement je me trouve avec à leonard
corti vous êtes le secrétaire général
bonjour merci de répondre à la question
alors expliquez nous pourquoi ce
rassemblement aujourd'hui quelles sont
concrètement vos revendications
alors les revendications comportent les
internes elles sont de deux ordres sont
d'abord sur l'hôpital public sur la
crise que vit l'hôpital public on
demande aux pouvoirs publics de enfin se
saisir de la question et de prendre
l'ampleur de ce qui secoue l'hôpital
public d'un an depuis plusieurs mois
avec d'abord le les urgences qui sont
mises en grève depuis le mois d'avril
2010 9 puis ensuite au mois de septembre
le mouvement qui a été rejoint par la
plupart des personnels hospitaliers et
on porte aussi des revendications plus
sur notre statut avec une inde est
content
horaires de notre temps de travail qui
est quand même un peu un principe de
base qui respecte et dans la plupart des
professions et qui pour les internes est
pas respectée avec des horaires qui
dépasse les 55 à 56 heures hebdomadaires
pour un temps légal de 48 heures et
ensuite respect de notre formation avec
des réformes qui sont menées un peu de
manière brutale sans ré concertation
avec les représentants des internes et
aussi une revalorisation des différentes
indemnités que touchent les internes
pour le regard doux pour le logement
voilà pour les revendications ce
rassemblement devrait se poursuivre ici
jusqu'à 17 heures mais pour christophe
prudhomme porte parole des médecins
urgentistes de france le gouvernement
est clairement responsable de la
situation dans les hôpitaux publics
quand les gens qui nous gouvernent nous
disent c'est une question d'organisation
c'est pas une question de moyens ça
suffit voyez la colère est là ce
gouvernement est minoritaire aujourd'hui
il peut pas s'appuyer sur la pseudo
démocratie de l'élection dia maintenant
presque trois ans pour justifier tous
ses mauvais coups voilà aujourd'hui
l'hôpital public est à l'agonie
ça entraîne des morts voilà mais je le
dis fortement ça entraîne des morts est
aujourd'hui monsieur macro madame
d'uzein les députés qui ont voté la loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale qui
continue entre aigle et financièrement
l'hôpital is ils sont responsables de
ces morts de ces gens qu'on pourrait
sauver si on avait les moyens de prendre
en charge correctement sept hommes
soupçonnés de préparer un attentat ont
été interpellés et placés en garde à vue
l'opération a été menée aujourd'hui par
la dgs ia bresse notamment et dans les
communes communes environnementale selon
des sources judiciaires les suspects
projeté aussi de se rendre dans la zone
yako syrienne et pour décrypter
l'actualité aujourd'hui nous sommes avec
jean marie bigard humoristes on ne sait
pas bien on va en parler avec lui à
l'instant s'il est déjà ou encore un
candidat sur la liste libérons paris de
marcel campion c'est notre invité ce
soir
[Musique]
bonsoir jean marie bigard merci de me
recevoir
merci d'être avec nous en direction rt
france alors candidat ou pas candidat
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on vous
présente et dans ces listes ont pas
publiées alors voilà les listes seront
publiées le 27 février donc ce soit bien
clair on est pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de listes ya pas de tête de liste elles
ne sont pas encore dévoilés mais moi
j'ai une amitié avec marcel campion qui
date de 30 ans je suis venu le soutenir
c'est très clair parce que c'est un il
est apolitique j'en fais partie d'aucun
parti précisément et que j'aime bien sa
démarche et puis le petit vent de de
liberté il souffle par la bouche d'un
d'un électron libre
on va dire qu'il fait pas trop peur à
qui que ce soit on est bien d'accord
mais quand même faut voir pour voir les
gens peuvent aimer ce petit souffle de
liberté mais ce que vous avez envie d'y
aller
oui je suis très clairement pour le
pousser pour le pour l'encourager à je
suis
j'allais dire comme les millions de
parisiens et d'utilisateurs de paris je
suis exaspéré par la gestion lamentable
qui a été fait sur paris par madame
hidalgo et donc ça m'est insupportable
de voir que on peut laisser une femme
qui n'a aucune autorité pour être à ce
poste aucune légitimité puisque elle a
même perdu
battu à plate couture dans son propre
arrondissement le 15e arrondissement
elle a fait 35% et cette femme par le
jeu des lois et des règles se retrouve
sur le trône de paris donc c'est
insupportable parce que laisser une
femme faire à l'abri paris quasiment à
zéro
elle a fait 6 milliards de dette c'est
pas mal quand même faut y aller un pour
faire faut pas chômé pour faire 6
milliards et l'idée que cette femme
puisse reproduire la même chose dans les
cinq ans qui viennent
refaire un nouveau 6 milliards elle a
précisé que les 8300 chantier ça
changerait pas ce serait toujours la
même chose pour rire la circulation dans
paris laissait cette ville qui était la
plus belle ville du monde envahi par la
saleté par les rats et tout est bien je
me dis je suis une personnalité et à
coton quand on a le bras qui va loin où
la voix qui porte
ils foutent pense qu'il faut donner son
avis à grand pouvoir grande
responsabilité
c'est dans ce pays dorman alors on va
parler de ce sondage à plusieurs titres
puisque sondage ifop 1 pour les
municipales paru hier chez nos confrères
du journal du dimanche qui doit pas vous
faire plaisir parce que oui ils notent
quand même y donne anne hidalgo en tête
en quelques jours après sa déclaration
de candidature 25% marcel campion 0,5
pour cent est ce que pour vraiment être
utile il aurait pas mieux fallu
peut-être s'engager sur un candidat qui
avait peut-être d'allant de mort au sens
déjà au jour d'aujourd'hui aucun sondage
qui ne vaut quoi que ce soit un marcel
très bien libérons paris s'est plutôt
bien finir à 5 6%
bon pourquoi pas et à 5 6% devient
dangereux pour tout le monde donc c'est
assez rigolo de participer à cette
aventure
et puis ensuite bon ben je si je dois le
rappeler ici à cause de la loi plm donc
la loi paris lyon marseille ce ne sont
pas ni les parisiens ni les lyonnaises
et les lyonnais lille et marseillaise
marseillais qui élisent leur mère dans
ces trois villes là ce sont les
conseillers municipaux et donc
évidemment comme eux ils sont déjà en
place
elle se retrouve naturellement favorite
mais sans le peuple
alors voilà par exemple quelque chose
qui m'exaspère si au vote universel
direct par exemple on faisait un sondage
comme celui du journal du dimanche
on va dire quels frais 8% quoi est il
faut expliquer à tous les français et à
madame hidalgo en particulier que pour
être le maire de sa ville dans toutes
les les autres villes
de france faut 50% plus une voix
mary construit pour ça on les élit par
arrondissement donc on sait très bien
qu'ils vont voter après de l'eau donc
c'est quand même une forme de démocratie
ben c'est une forme avec comme on dit un
filtre c'est le peuple
on demande juste aux peuples de fermer
sa gueule au moment de prendre la
décision
ce n'est pas du tout logique que lier
une exception pour les trois plus
grandes villes de france
nous réclamons le vote pour notre mère
d'abord il y aurait plus de gens qui
auraient voté à paris parce que c'est
une cata la catastrophe je vais vous
dire où elle et stéphanie sait qu'il ya
deux millions deux cent quarante mille
parisien il ya seulement un million qui
ont leur carte d'électeur et sur ce
million il ya nakheel 600 milles qui
votent et là on peut pas y arriver
c'est à dire si les gens se disaient
c'est nous qui allons élire notre maire
assurant là bas ils prendraient plus
volontiers leur cas et les irait plus
volontiers faire leur devoir civique
donc c'est vers ça que je veux
encourager les gens si tu veux te
plaindre va voter c'est le seul moment
où le peuple a le pouvoir c'est pendant
le petit dixième de seconde ou le
bulletin tombe dans l'urne
alors j'appelle c'est fini c'est vrai
qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de parisiens qui
estiment capables beaucoup de choix mon
très satisfaisant de candidats c'est ce
qu'on entend ici ou là il ya aussi la
rivalité benjamin griveaux cédric
villani qui a eu deux font finalement
28% au total rachida dati qui talonne se
bouffer le quai rachida dati qui fait
une percée 1 19% toujours selon ces
sondages
vous aviez à l'époque on s'en souvient
en 2007 ça fait longtemps que la vie ait
regretté depuis ils sont tenus nicolas
sarkozy qui était très proche de rachida
dati qui était sa garde des sceaux vous
pourriez par exemple sont ni rachida
dati
je les adore c'est elle qui m'a marier
avec avec ma femme de ce que tu es dans
le 7e arrondissement et elle s'est
déplacé pour venir nous nous marier donc
ses études dans la vie c'est une amie et
donc je suis très content pour elle
qu'elle fasse un très bon score qu'elles
soient pour l'instant si j'ai bien
compris en seconde position
vous pourriez la soutenir et à je peux
je pourrais oui c'est à dire quand les
jeux seront un peu plus ce fait quand il
faudra faire un choix si vous me
demandez s'il choisit anne hidalgo ou à
rachida dati vie d'avant que j'ai mille
ponction j'ai choisi rachida dati
de toute façon c'est impossible de faire
une gestion plus mauvaise de paris que
celle de anne hidalgo qui encore une
fois n'a aucune légitimité pour occuper
ce poste
aujourd'hui votre voix est entendue nous
avait l'impression d'être écoutés avec
où j'ai l'impression qu'on veut me faire
fermer ma gueule ce qui est plutôt déjà
une bonne chose
apparemment nous a ici pas ici merci
merci à tous pas ici mais par exemple
delphine ernotte me dire de la chaîne
publique c'est-à-dire à l'interdît on
est en 2020 on est on est en france un
vous souvenez de sa cause les gens se
rappellent bien de sa 2020 france et l
m'interdit comme à l'époque de giscard
d'estaing où on disait giscard est
montré du doigt quelqu'un il a lui fini
puis télé c'était l'aspect ce de
dictature douce que notre jeu un peu
vécu en france 3 mais bon c'est l
approche à notre avis c'est la question
que je me pose c'est à dire que d'abord
je suis honoré je tiens à dire delphine
ernotte ciel mais couteau ce moment je
suis honoré qu'elle mais censuré parce
que je rentre dans le panthéon des gens
formidables korité par le passé censuré
je parle du chanteur renaud de coluche 2
toi ou plus récemment de patrick
sébastien par exemple donc je suis
plutôt honoré c'est une médaille pour
moi c'est mon molière à moi d'être
censuré à la différence des autres et
critiquer ouvertement donc les gens qui
nous gouvernaient à l'époque
moi j'ai rien fait de tout ça mais jean
marie bigard tout de même vous avouer ce
que vous acceptez que je vous dit vous
savez bien vous jouer parfois la
provocation il ya eu quelques petits
scandales sur quelques plateaux est ce
que voilà vous regrettez pas justement
finalement que ça puisse nuire à votre
image ne craignez-vous pas entre les
scènes de nuit pas à mon image puisque
les les gens qui nous gouvernent sont
des bras cassés
donc moi je suis très volontiers amis
des gilet jaune je les soutiens depuis
le début et sans intermittence je suis
un ami de la police c'est donc moi j'ai
ma voix est libre et c'est bon des fois
de respirer un peu de liberté donc
chaque fois qu'on me sanctionne ou comme
condamne je gagne des des followers
je gagne trois cent mille abonnés à
chaque fois donc je peux pas leur en
vouloir
il me renforce en fait parce que quand
on fait partie d'aucune famille ce qui
est mon cas mais si ce n'est de la
famille des forums avec marcel campion
et bien on a toutes les familles contre
soi à l'époque que lui chez disaient
tous les partis sont venus me voir me
disant vous ne craignez rien de nous
mais méfiez vous des autres quand vous
dites vous êtes amis des gilets jaunes
et de la police vous savez qu'il ya une
polémique évidemment ça vous a pas
échappé aujourd'hui d'ailleurs marine le
pen et olivier faure le socialiste
demande tous deux le départ du préfet de
police de paris à cette incompréhension
vous guerrier ce malentendu
beaucoup de violences policières ce
manifestant d'ailleurs qui porte plainte
les trois policiers aussi quelle est
votre réaction quand on se dit ami des
deux voilà c'est à dire lui l'usure et
les nerfs craquent de tous les côtés
c'est à dire tout le monde peut craquer
il ya que nos gouvernants qui peuvent
mettre siffle la fin du match mais il ne
la siffle pas ils s'en foutent c'est à
dire le gouvernant n'écoute pas le
peuple peuple gronde et de plus en plus
en colère
les policiers sont de plus en plus
dépassés ne me mets à la place des uns
et des autres et c'est absolument
logique et normale celle inverse qui
serait étonnant que évidemment comme dit
un ami on a peur on fait pas de coquard
sans casser des yeux et effectivement la
violence elle est forcément lié à tout
mouvement social et la police ils en ont
ras-le-bol vraiment ils sont utilisés à
1000% et puis je sais pas ce qu'on
attend que tout le monde craque au
qu'elle soit vraiment le chaos pour
intervenir
non on a des dirigeants on a de sécurité
on a tout ce qu'il faut siffler la fin
du match mais a eu l'impression que ça
les intéresse pas trop rapidement parce
qu'on arrive déjà à la fin de cette
interview le gouvernement aux règles
clairement dû retirer cette réforme des
retraites avant que cette violence
arrivent la grève se muant viol
c'est-à-dire on sait très bien qu'il y
ait une loi qui se prépare on met le la
barre ici et on sait très bien qu'il
faudra reculer
donc il aurait été peut-être été plus
adroits de reculer plus vite pour
éteindre le feu quoi certainement là on
laisse bien pourrir le truc jusqu'au
jusqu'à ce que les débordements soir
insupportable pour tout le monde
merci jean marie bigard d'avoir été avec
nous
reçus merci avec mon direct donc sur rt
français dans quelques instants
restez avec nous donc nous irons à nous
irons en irak ou trois manifestantes
étaient tués à bagdad lors
d'affrontements entre forces de sécurité
et opposants au pouvoir et puis nous
reviendrons sur la crise au liban le
président convoque une réunion de
sécurité après les heurts du week end
entre manifestants et forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent à l on
soit vient des lignes ont aujourd'hui
une gauche l'extrême user de tous les
témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
c'est ça le problème
voyez ces mahomet les gens n'aiment pas
qu'on dessine mahomet comme ça
ds
vous savez avec la montée du radicalisme
et du nombre de fanatiques
il faut prendre les menaces au sérieux
quiconque peut venir nous attaquer
pendant que nous faisons cela alors
je ne sais pas si je vais rester à
dessiner ici caricature j'espère que je
suis du bon côté du côté obscur
[Musique]
les news ne s'arrête jamais mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
qu'est-ce que tu m'apportes 1
mais pourquoi tu m'as tu là qu'est ce
que tu m'as toi qu'est ce tu maintenant
au alors un vase il vient pas peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis sur la voie de gandhi j'essaie
de le copier et même une mauvaise copie
comme war a de la valeur je ne suis pas
là pour faire de quiconque un disciple
de gandhi je suis là pour trouver le
futur j'en dis
t'inquiète que nous n'est pas seulement
utilisée pour filer c'est aussi
l'essence même des idées de gandhi c'est
la philosophie indienne
tab exploite ce que vous voyez autant de
riom est le reflet de ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de l'île c'est gandhi c'est
ce que j'ai compris après de nombreuses
années de travail
[Musique]
gandhi a lancé ce mouvement de liberté
vers cette voie
à douala
pour nous il est une incarnation de dieu
c'est pourquoi je le prie
je suis la seule personne encore en vie
qui travaillaient avec gandhi et qui
connaissait conduite
10 à 10 d'abord ils signeront ensuite
ils se moqueront de toi et enfin être
rejoindront
[Musique]
20h30 merci nous rejoint en direct sur
rt france dans l'actualité protestations
antigouvernementales également en irak
les manifestants relance la contestation
pour demander à l'exécutif d'apporter
les réponses à leurs revendications
trois personnes sont mortes aujourd'hui
à bagdad selon les médecins depuis
octobre environ 460 personnes ont perdu
la vie françois xavier lambert
[Musique]
c'est devenu un rituel pour ces
manifestants le visage masqué drapeaux
irakiens en main ils continuent de se
mobiliser au milieu de nous enflammer
déposés sur les grands axes des
principales villes d'irak
mais ces barricades de fortune n'évite
pas les affrontements avec la police
anti émeute
les forces de l'ordre multiplient les
jets de gaz lacrymogènes mais aussi les
tirs à balles réelles pour disperser les
protestataires
aujourd'hui nous bloquons les routes en
solidarité avec les populations de
naciria il a et bagdad
nous avons dit que nos manifestations
étaient pacifiques mais les policiers
nous ont tiré dessus
demain on brûlera plus si on ira au
régime corrompu ne sous-estimé pas les
manifestants les manifestants avaient
fixé un ultimatum au gouvernement pour
répondre à leurs demandes
un ultimatum qui expire ce lundi parmi
ces revendications des élections
anticipées
une réforme de la loi électorale la fin
de la corruption ou encore la
désignation d'un premier ministre
indépendant démissionnaire adel mahdi
continue à diriger le pays alors que les
partis politiques ne s'entendent pas sur
un successeur à cette situation
politique incertaine s'ajoute un
contexte régional toujours explosif
après les récents événements entre les
etats-unis et l'iran de pays très
influent en irak en embrasement lié à la
mort du général iranien qasem soleimani
tués par un raid américain près de
l'aéroport de bagdad au début du mois
depuis octobre
les violences en irak ont coûté la vie à
près de cas
360 personnes et fait plus de 25 mille
blessés
et pour françois quand storming docteur
en sciences politiques le gouvernement
irakien en cherche à gagner du temps le
gréement irakiens cherchent à gagner du
temps face à cette contestation sans
précédent qui est dans le pays ensuite
il faut savoir que les les même si la
tension entre iran etats unis quelque
peu retombée au moins de façon
momentanée les questions géopolitiques
les questions stratégiques ne sont pas
absents suisse on sait très bien que
dans les manifestations il ya beaucoup
de choses il ya en effet des
revendications aux primaires qui
explique l'importance des manifestations
qui sont d'ailleurs 34 ans
confessionnelle mais il ya également
dans une certaine mesure le jeu entre
l'iran jeu de l'iran et certains pôles
chiites irakiens qui prend forme dans
les danses atteindre de randy aux
indications pour le moment on peut dire
qu'il n'ya pas de véritables
perspectives pour le gouvernement
irakien
donc on s'interroge encore sur les
compromis qui peuvent est un lieu mais
tout vient d'informer sur investissement
en irak un gouvernement de compromis
et pour en parler nous sommes savait
qu'à claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir je
maison merci d'être avec nous alors on
vient de voir la contestation qui
continue m
et même amplifient on ira contre le
gouvernement quatre morts en deux jours
on ne connaît pas le nom du successeur
du premier ministre démissionnaire
c'était c'est cette instabilité selon
vous qui créez des heures je crois que
la tragédie pour le peuple irakien
continuelle
elle existe depuis longtemps
exister avec évidemment saddam hussein
qui était un dictateur autoritaire mais
lorsque les américains ont décidé
d'entrer en guerre en 2003 pour le faire
partir et pour le supprimer
finalement ils ont créé une autre forme
d'instabilité dans la zone est
effectivement puisque une majorité de la
population est d'origine chiite de
confession chiite
c'est un gouvernement qui est plutôt
d'obédience chiite qui a pris le pouvoir
et donc ceci va va va durer il se trouve
que la population notamment les jeunes
en ont assez assez de ce régime corrompu
puisque je crois que ils ont même
calculé que en 16 ans plusieurs fois le
pnb de l'irak avait disparu dans les
poches cela de la queue de la corruption
des dirigeants et je crois qu'ils n'ont
ils ne sont pas dupes non plus du fait
que le premier ministre démissionnaire
mais qui est toujours là monsieur mady a
cherché à utiliser la disparition
général soleimani du fait de
l'intervention des américains son
assassinat par un drone américain pour
détourner l'attention et en effet
pendant quelques jours ça a marché
pendant quelques jours les
manifestations étaient contre
l'intervention américaine sur le sol
irakien
il est assez logique que les irakiens ne
souhaite pas que en effet les querelles
entre les iraniens et américains se
transpose en guerre sur le le sol
irakien
mais au bout du compte ils en sont
revenus à leurs revendications
fondamentales qui sont des
revendications contre la corruption pour
un changement de gouvernement
pour une nouvelle loi électorale pour un
changement d'équipé et on voit bien que
ceci va en effet durer et ne peut que
s'accentuer alors il apparaît que les
manifestants demandent le départ des
milices iraniennes et des soldats
américains de l'irak ni les unes ni les
autres ne sont plié bagage est ce que la
situation va évoluer dans quel sens donc
non alors les iraniens bien entendu
utilise le fait qu' une majorité de la
population soit de confession chiite
pour essayer de les prendre sous leur
coupe
d'ailleurs je vois pas pourquoi sous
prétexte qu'ils sont chiites il serait
nécessairement sous la coupe des
iraniens ya des chiites irakiens qui est
même des ddd des religieux chiites
irakiens qui sans doute ont lors une
autonomie par rapport à l'iran
donc effectivement l'iran continue à
exploiter sa position dominante
un petit peu comme le fait également au
liban c'est l'arc site qui lui donne un
accès jusqu'au liban jusqu'à la mer
méditerranée et ça c'est une
préoccupation importante mais
effectivement la population notamment
les jeunes demandent le départ des
troupes étrangères
il ya peu de chances que les milices
iraniennes se retire et du côté des
américains il ya également assez peu de
chances que les américains se retirent
puisqu'ils sont venus là avec une
coalition d'ailleurs pour lutter contre
des ch et qui considère que la menace
est toujours là
ils sont aussi venus là comme d'ailleurs
d'autres troupes de la coalition pour
former des soldats irakiens pour les
former de manière efficace moderne et
aussi en faire une arme et démocratique
alors ya une chercheuse un millième mend
qui dit les états unis après leur
intervention en irak ont aidé le schisme
politique à se mettre en place
offrant l'irak 1 sur un plateau d'argent
à l'iran est ce que vous pensez que ça
peut changer avec la contestation
actuelle
oui je crois que tout ça c'est un peu
dépassé je crois que les jeunes en ont
assez de ces clivages anciens
on le voit aussi dans les pays voisins
d'ailleurs et en ont assez de la
corruption généralisée d'une vieille
classe politique qui est tout à fait au
bout du rouleau
donc je pense que en effet ce que
demande la jeunesse en réalité
exclusivement des manifestants c'est un
gouvernement de transition
peut-être de technocrates qui soit un
gouvernement efficace qui puisse
remettre l'économie irakienne sur pied
préparer une nouvelle loi électorale et
réparer des élections merci beaucoup
claude la blanche maison d'avoir été
avec nous en direct where they france
expert en relations internationales
les violences ce week end à beyrouth
entre militants anti système et
policiers anti émeutes ont fait plus de
520 blessés les manifestants exigent
depuis trois mois le départ de la classe
politique qu'il juge corrompu et
inefficace
jordi demory le liban a connu ce
week-end le plus violent depuis le début
de la contestation le 17 octobre dernier
d'importants affrontements ont eu lieu
samedi et dimanche entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre à beyrouth
bilan plus de 520 blessés deux jours de
suite la police anti émeute a tiré des
balles en caoutchouc et des grenades
lacrymogènes à l'entrée d'une avenue
menant au parlement où étaient
rassemblés les contestataires depuis le
début du mouvement il ya trois mois la
colère n'a fait que croître
les manifestants fustige l'apathie des
dirigeants alors que la crise économique
s'aggrave il y à peu nous avons appris
que ce gouvernement s'est effondré
qu'ils n'ont pas réussi à s'entendre
c'est normal parce que les voleurs ne
peuvent pas s'entendre entre eux chacun
veut gagner un plus gros morceau au
profit du peuple appauvri
nous rejetons tout gouvernement qui
comprend des personnes de ces partis qui
nous ont volés
nous continuerons de manifester de
bloquer les routes et nous ne quitterons
pas les rues tant que la révolution
n'aura pas triomphé obtenu ce qu'elle
veut en réaction à ce week-end de
violences le président libanais michel
aoun a convoqué ce lundi une réunion de
sécurité
parmi les présents les ministres de la
défense et de l'intérieur mais aussi des
hauts gradés des forces de la police et
de l'armée
l'objectif est de discuter des
développements sur le plan sécuritaire
et des mesures à prendre pour préserver
la stabilité et le calme
de son côté la france est dit préoccupé
par ces violences et souligne l'urgence
de la formation d'un nouveau
gouvernement dans la grave crise
économique et sociale que traverse le
liban et compte tenu des violences
récentes l'urgence et qu'un nouveau
gouvernement met en oeuvre un ensemble
crédible de réformes pour répondre aux
attentes exprimées par les libanais
depuis plus de 3
moi la france entend comme toujours se
tenir aux côtés du peuple libanais
l'impasse politique s'ajoute à la crise
depuis la démission fin octobre du
premier ministre saad hariri hassan diab
désigné comme son successeur le 19
décembre n'a toujours pas formé son
équipe
les tractations avec les grands partis
traîne chaque faction cherchant à
garantir sa représentation au sein de la
future équipe
dans la rue les manifestants réclament
inlassablement un gouvernement de
technocrates indépendants de l'actuelle
classe dirigeante quasi inchangé depuis
des décennies et de son côté l' ong
human right watch au moyen-orient
dénonce une impunité et des abus
policiers lors des violents
affrontements du week end
il n'y avait aucune justification pour
le recours brutal à la force par la
police anti-émeute libanaise contre des
manifestants largement pacifiques dans
le centre-ville de beyrouth le 18
janvier
la police anti émeute a montré un mépris
flagrant matière de droits de l'homme en
tirant des cartouches de gaz lacrymogène
sur la tête des manifestants et des
balles en caoutchouc dans les yeux en
attaquant les personnes dans des
hôpitaux et une mosquée les événements
de la nuit dernière ont montré qu'il
était urgent que les autorités mettent
fin à cette culture d'impunité pour les
abus de la police l iran menace de se
retirer du traité sur la non
prolifération des armes nucléaires
annonce aujourd'hui en réponse au
déclenchement par les européennes un
mécanisme de règlement des différends
contre téhéran
le chef de la diplomatie iranienne
mohammad jawad arrive dénonce l'absence
pas de base légale ce processus permet
au conseil des nations unies de rétablir
les sanctions évité grâce à l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien
traité dont washington s'est retiré en
mai 2010huit paris berlin et londres
disent rester engagés au sein de ce
texte téhéran les accuse d'inaction
écouter le porte parole du ministère des
affaires étrangères iranien
si ces discussions se poursuivent l'iran
prépare une mesure finale et même plus
efficace dont je ne connais pas les
détails pour le moment
différentes options pour l'iran sont sur
la table et elles seront annoncées
si nous parvenons à un consensus
vladimir poutine soumis aujourd'hui au
parlement un ensemble d'amendements
constitutionnels le président russe a
présenté à les changements proposés dans
son discours sur l'état de la nation est
destinée à renforcer le rôle du
parlement et à consolider la démocratie
la chambre basse a reçu un projet de loi
sur les propositions constitutionnelles
du kremlin et a rapidement au g est la
première des trois lectures requises
projet ni ses traits forme impliquera le
transfert de plus de pouvoir aux
citoyens de notre pays afin qu'ils
puissent participer plus efficacement au
gouvernement en s'attaquant aux
problèmes auxquels notre pays est
confronté
en même temps le pouvoir présidentiel
reste fort basé sur les questions liées
à l'évaluation des activités des
fonctionnaires fédéraux du premier
ministre des responsables régionaux et
sur la possibilité de les révoquer la
suite de la guerre commerciale
sino-américaine début aujourd'hui des
audiences sur la demande d'extradition
aux états unis de la directrice
financière de huawai selon la loi
canadienne
meng wang sont ou pourraient être
extradés vers washington
clément hospital son arrestation a
provoqué une grave crise diplomatique
entre la chine et le canada
la directrice financière de huawei et
fille du fondateur de l'entreprise
chinoise est accusé par les autorités
américaines d'avoir contourné leurs
sanctions contre l'iran et d'avoir volé
des secrets industriels du groupe
américain ti mobile arrêté en décembre
2018 lors d'une escale au canada
la numéro deux du géant chinois des
télécommunications vit depuis en liberté
surveillée
et pour échapper à son renvoi devant la
justice américaine mad band tout va
devoir convaincre aujourd'hui le juge
canadien que les accusations retenues
seraient motivées par des considérations
politiques comme le martèle la chine
depuis près d'un an
la chine a une position claire et
cohérente sur le cas de maywand jouent
les etats-unis et le canada à mu de
l'accord bilatéral d'extradition et
prennent arbitrairement des mesures
coercitives secret gravement atteinte
aux droits et intérêts légitimes de 75
chinoise il s'agit d'un grave incident
politique sa détention avait déclenché
la colère de pékin
ouvrant la voie à une crise sans
précédent entre les deux pays les
autorités chinoises avaient arrêté
quelques jours plus tard deux citoyens
canadiens pour espionnage un événement
comme aig pompéo avait dénoncé comme une
mesure de représailles la détention
arbitraire de deux citoyens canadiens en
chine est fondamentalement différente en
termes de droits de l'homme
ce sont des questions très différente de
la décision de les canadiens d'utiliser
une procédure prévue par la loi de se
comporter d'une manière qui est
profondément en accord avec celle des se
comportent les nations respectables et
en posant cette question vous les mettez
sur le même plan c'est comme ça que la
chine va en parler l'audience prévue
aujourd'hui devrait marquer un nouveau
rebondissement dans cette affaire
si l'infraction qui lui est reprochée ne
concerne pas le canada même en dessous
pourrait retrouver la liberté rapidement
dans le cas contraire le processus
d'extradition pourrait encore traîner
durant plusieurs années dans ce pays
pour la libye les représentants
internationaux réunis hier à berlin
s'accordent sur une déclaration commune
avec deux points majeurs la fin de
l'ingérence étrangère est le respect de
l'embargo sur les livraisons d'armes
théo combat avec emi digout gâchette
elles fâchent une deuxième
syrie voilà ce que veulent éviter les
parties prenantes du dossier libyen
les dirigeants des principaux pays
concernés par ce conflit ce sont
accordés sur un communiqué final mais
les tractations devraient se poursuivre
cette semaine selon l'hôte de cette
conférence le ministre allemand des
affaires étrangères
nous avons atteint notre objectif à la
conférence de berlin sur la libye hier
hier avec les deux parties à berlin nous
avons personnaliser la réunion 10 du
format 5 + 5
l envoyé spécial des nations unies
ghassan salamé va tenir une réunion
officielle cette semaine pour s'assurer
que le cessez le feu peut se transformer
en armistice le but est non seulement
d'appeler à un cessez le feu permanent
en libye mais aussi de mettre fin aux
interférences étrangères dans le pays le
secrétaire général des nations unies
antonio goûter res a insisté sur ce
point tous les participants se sont
engagés à s'abstenir de toute ingérence
dans le conflit armé ou les affaires
intérieures de la libye
cela fait partie des conclusions et bien
entendu elles doivent être respectées
ainsi que l'appel à faire taire les
armes à feu avec la fin de toute
hostilité militaire pour sa part le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov a regretté l'absence de
discussions directes entre les deux
camps rivaux libyen mais il a tenu à
saluer le pas en avant effectué pour
stabiliser une trêve fragile le cessez
le feu est entré en vigueur le 12
janvier à l'initiative de la russie de
la turquie
aujourd'hui on a constaté qu'il était
généralement respecté
bien que des violations aient lieu des
deux côtés
enfin les 11 participants ont appelé le
conseil de sécurité a imposé des
sanctions à ceux qui violeraient les
dispositions du cessez le feu et on
retourne vers le liban pour en parler
nous sommes avec roux la taz analyste
politique spécialiste du moyen-orient
bonsoir vous la table merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france une réunion
de sécurité s'est donc tenue en présence
des ministres de la défense et de
l'intérieur mais aussi des hauts gradés
des forces de la police et de l'armée
ce n'est pas vraiment la réponse
attendue par les manifestants n'ont
évidemment pas c'est pas une réponse
sécuritaire que les la la révolution at
en ce sens plus une réponse aux demandes
de réformes de réformes sérieuses à un
gouvernement qui représente le peuple et
ses droits on ne pas à plus de deux
demandes de topics nous demandons les
droits du peuple et c'est pas du tout
les
le la réponse qu'on attendait du
président de la république
malheureusement évidemment je pense
qu'ils ne comprennent que par la rai le
langage de la force
justement effectivement plus de salma
une appel à une escale à sion oui plus
de 500 blessés 1 ce week end le disais
tout à l'heure au liban comment vous
expliquer cette soudaine flambée de
violence alors que pour le moment les
manifestations se déroulaient quand même
plus ou moins dans le calme elle est
allée mais les manifestations pendant
trois mois on était des manifestations
pacifistes pensant que les dirigeants
allaient comprendre le message pacifiste
des gens les gens ont mal les gens ont
faim et c'est surtout pas une révolution
politique alors un clan politique a
pensé faire le malin et prendre le
dessus
prendre le former un gouvernement par la
force des choses un gouvernement d'une
seule couleur un parti un groupement
politique ou un acte politique contre un
autre alors que c'est pas ça du tout les
manifestants ne veulent aucun des
représentants qui ont qui ont été dans
la vie politique d'une façon ou d'une
autre que ce soit pendant la guerre
civile ou après nous avons des demandes
de gens qui ont mal qui ont qui ont faim
et c'est c'est une vraie révolution et
ils n'arrivent pas à le comprendre et
pendant trois mois les gens en sont
restées pacifiste est maintenant de plus
en plus des gens ont faim et quand les
gens ont faim les gens deviennent
violents et les gens pollitt les gens
pacifistes comme moi même et plein
d'amis même si on a mal on est
on essaie de tempérer et ça fait déjà un
mois qu'on demande aux gouvernements
existants ou aux jambes aux politiciens
quoi de faire très attention parce que
les gens pacifistes comme nous ne
pourrons plus retenir les gens qui ont
vraiment mal et quand on a mal on casse
tout et ce week end était juste un petit
exemple de ce qui pourrait arriver et je
pense le pire est encore n'est pas
encore arrivé et d'un autre côté les
droits de deux les les forces de
sécurité en particulier les gens de la
sécurité du parlement qui sont d'un côté
qui ne sont pas exactement parti ou au
quine qui ne prennent pas leurs ordres
du de la police interne mais plutôt du
président du parlement ont utilisé une
force vraiment très difficile à décrire
ils ont fait du tir direct vers l'est
envers les manifestants on a 400 blessés
400 blessés dont quelques-uns qui ont
perdu la vue parce qu ils tirer sur les
manifestants tout droit dans les yeux
sur les têtes bon et ça je ne sais pas
où est ce que ça va mener mais
les pacifistes de cette révolution non
plus leur mot à dire c'est les gens qui
sont très en colère qui vont diriger
dorénavant les manifestations merci
beaucoup roulent à talange d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france retour
en france où il existe une soixantaine
de monnaies locales des devises qui ne
compte que quelques centaines
d'utilisateurs mais l'une d'entre elles
est devenu en 2018 la première monnaie
alternative d'europe reportage à bayonne
de nadège abderrazak et jordi demory ici
payez en au choco l'inscription figure
sur de nombreuses vitrines du pays
basque créé en 2013
cette monnaie se veut complémentaire à
l'euro 1,5 millions de coupures sont
aujourd'hui en circulation dans la
région
objectif favoriser l'économie locale
l'idée c'est de 2
faire circuler les chevaux donc l'amont
et basque 1 euro égale 1-1 ce qu est de
privilégier les circuits courts c'est à
dire en gros que moi
le salaire que je peux avoir et gêné
parti qui vient est ce qu avec ça je
vais payer mon pea neige co je vais
aller au bar en esko je vais payer la
scolarité de mes enfants en esko et les
gens qui vont recevoir de l'argent de ma
part
eux ils vont aller acheter le journal
les médias bas c'est peut-être un escroc
en fait c'est l'idée c'est de que ça
circule en circuit court que c'est sur
un territoire bien de bien tourner le
pays basque nord est de plus en plus
d'entreprises d'associations adhèrent à
ce projet là et donc du coup cet argent
il reste au niveau local à lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique c'est
l'autre avantage de cette monnaie locale
elle gérée par l'association euskal
moneta on a déjà beaucoup d'utilisateurs
particuliers des citoyens qui avons déjà
une consommation en mains des
responsables qui vengera bio ou alors
qu'elles font les courses au marché dans
les commerces à proximité
on ne sait d'ailleurs plutôt qu'une
bouchée qu'on supermarché entre firmes
morisi fille à courte on fait tout ça en
euros on peut le faire en euros
l'intérêt qu'on utilise une monnaie
locale
c'est que quand on paye en monnaies
locales à un commerçant lui-même
derrière il va devoir soit révisé la
monnaie locale auprès d'autres
entreprises du réseau
donc forcément des entreprises que le
siège social sur le territoire
localement sinon on va devant les
reconvertir en euros hélas une
commission de reconversion chez nous qui
ne sommes pour cent et du coup c'est un
petit peu dissuasif du coup 56% des
entreprises du réseau à ce qu ont pris
au moins un nouveau fournisseur local
pour pouvoir réutiliser les eaux
actuellement un millier
deux commerces ou entreprises utilisent
le ch kof dans les 158 communes du pays
basque
ça permet de financer des entreprises
localement parce qu'à une partie qui
reversés aux entreprises et parce que ça
permet de vivre de faire vivre ici les
entrepreneurs locaux les petites
épiceries et ses jeux provinciaux
canadiens
on peut pas faire ça avec l'euro ah ben
non parce que disons que ça sensibilise
davantage les gens et cela permet de
voilà justement de rester sur ce petit
circuit leur hausse et obliger
international et anonyme
alors qu'ici c'est leur vie si par
principe parce que c'est un moyen
d'activer l'économie locale
j'en suis convaincu puisque la
maintenant j'avais des histoires des
pensées et géré ou ce qu'on va dans quel
restaurant va-t-on manger
celui qui accepte et escaut donc c'est
bien un avantage pour celui qui les
acceptent conçu pour être au service de
l'économie locale et de la langue basque
le ch kof a aussi une démarche solidaire
3 % du montant total converti est en
effet chaque année
reversés à des associations locales 1
dans quelques instants en rester avec
nous nous reviendrons sur les
déplacements aujourd'hui des manuels
mais croit dunkerque et versailles
perturbé par la colère des avocats ou
ponctuée par des manifestants contre la
réforme des retraites
et puis nous parlerons de la centaine de
conteneurs de déchets plastiques
illégaux qui ont été renvoyés par la
malaisie vers leur pays d'origine dont
43 en france
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit c'est
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
parce qu'ici seul interdit d'interdire
[Musique]
les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture sont
comme des livres ouverts sur les siècles
passés
[Musique]
les contempler ces découvrir le regard
que portent les artistes sur leur époque
[Musique]
il est un thème qui a toujours eu une
place à part dans l'histoire de l'art
c'est celui de l'enfance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le regard de l'artiste a changé
entre cet enfant iconique peint sous les
traits de jésus par jean fouquet et sept
enfants couverts de toute la tendresse
de sa mère peint par elisabeth vigée
lebrun
entre le regard triste de cette jeune
fille contraint de vendre ses charmes
dans les rues de londres et
l'insouciance de cet enfant à qui le
suisse félix vallotton donne la liberté
de ne même pas regardé le peintre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter les enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
ils sont élevés dans un seul but
ils ont un super pouvoir
il commence à s'entraîner dès le plus
jeune âge
huit mois de formation intense
ce sont des rats et il sauve des vies
humaines
natation assez les chiens nordiques
j'irai donc le chien de race husky de
sibérie et qu'est ce qu'ils représentent
pour vous ces chiens a remué représente
plein de choses parce que c'est de
l'amour de l'amour au quotidien je
chassais pas une motoneige assez bonne
machine c'est pour vous faire plaisir
bien souvent qui courent chaque chine a
son caractère il ya certaines de mes
chiennes avec lequel ryan par le regard
on arrive à se comprendre
cette année on a fait un parcours à
l'envers arrivé à un moment depuis des
années enfin à gauche
cette année elle nous a fait prendre la
piste par la droite au fait comment
alors la chienne de tête à s'est
retourné et m'a dit tu es sur ton coup
parce que c'est pas par là qu'il faut
aller c'est d'autre côté
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france 21h heure française deuxième
démission voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi
la double comité d'accueil hostile pour
emmanuel macron le président en visite
ce matin dans une usine de dunkerque
symbole de l'attractivité française est
en représentation cet après midi à
versailles face à 200 patrons étrangers
deux rendez vous lors desquels le chef
de l'état a été reçue par des
manifestants opposés à la réforme des
retraites
elle ne veut pas devenir une décharge
pour les pays développés la malaisie a
renvoyé 150 conteneurs de déchets
plastiques vers plusieurs pays dont 43
vers la france une décision qui fit
celles déjà prises par l'indonésie et
les philippines alors que certaines
localités se trouvent submergé par les
déchets le maintien de l'ordre dans le
collimateur des responsables politiques
réclament la démission du préfet de
police de paris après la diffusion de
vidéos montrant un policier frapper un
manifestant au sol en marge d'une
manifestation de gilet jaune le ministre
de l'intérieur demande des explications
le fonctionnaire de police impliqués de
ses collègues ont porté plainte contre
les manifestants peut-on encore
organiser des manifestations son
débordement en france peut-on manifester
sans danger ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face à 21h30
[Musique]
emmanuel macron était en visite
aujourd'hui à dunkerque et versailles
est l'occasion pour le chef de l'état de
défendre ses réformes sur l'emploi et
l'innovation à l'occasion de la journée
et schultz friends mais aussi l'occasion
de constater une nouvelle fois un
accueil hostile
elles sont arrivées florian lambert une
journée mouvementée pour emmanuel macron
en visite ce lundi matin dans l'usiné
pharmaceutique astrazeneca dunkerque
le chef de l'état défend ses réformes
sur l'emploi et l'innovation devant
quelques 300 employés du groupe anglo
suédois
mais à quelques mètres de lusine une
cinquantaine de manifestants cgt et une
dizaine d'avocats du barreau de
dunkerque sont présents et souhaite
interpeller le président contre le
projet de réforme des retraites
nous avons souhaité rencontrer
effectivement monsieur emmanuel macron
ou ses proches pour le sensibiliser à
notre interpellation
les avocats sont en grève depuis
maintenant 15 jours cette grève a été
reconduite de nouveau pendant une
semaine les avocats n'accepte pas la
réforme que l'on veut leur imposer en
termes de régimes de retraite il s'agit
en réalité et bien d'une manifestation
nationale et l'ensemble des barreaux de
france et de navarre sont actuellement
en grève pour et bien faire pression
pour le gouvernement auprès du
gouvernement pour pouvoir être
simplement entendus pour faire valoir
effectivement leurs observations il
fallait qu'on soit là
bien évidemment pour accueillir le
président des riches et lui faire savoir
qu'on était totalement déterminée sur le
dunkerquois comme comme ailleurs dans le
pays pour obtenir le retrait de cette
réforme comprend pas depuis plusieurs
semaines dans l'après midi emmanuel
macron seront un versailles afin de
rencontrer des patrons de venus du monde
entier pour la troisième édition du
sommet tous friends
comprenez choisissez la france seulement
pendant ce temps là un cortège de plus
de 300 manifestants selon les
organisateurs étaient présents devant le
château de versailles
portant des slogans au vitriol contre le
chef de l'état venir en pleine
mobilisation sociale d'une ampleur
historique avec les 200 plus grands
patrons se pavaner dans un lieu qui est
quand même symbolique d'un régime qui
est pas celui de la république terre à
versailles bon je trouve ça je crois que
parce qu'ils se rendent compte à quel
point c'est ça une image assez
insupportable au reste du pays il faut
montrer à ce gouvernement qu'il est
nulle part chez lui aujourd'hui quand on
est quand tu vois là il est accueilli
comme ça enfin accueilli quand il est
attendu à la sortie du théâtre par une
foule qui a envie de l'interpeller dû
poser des questions il se rend bien
compte que il est plus chez lui et nous
on est chez nous deux jours après sa
sortie mouvementée du théâtre des
bouffes du nord à paris
emmanuel macron a une nouvelle fois dû
sortir par la petite porte ce lundi et
pour en parler nous sommes avec gilles
casanova consultant en stratégie et
communication bonsoir chine chaise nova
merci d'être avec nous nouvelle journée
mouvementée on le disait pour emmanuel
macron
on se demande quand cela va s'arrêter
quelle est la chose qui pourrait stopper
cet engrenage
c'est très clair l'élection d'un nouveau
président serait quelque chose qui
stopperait cet engrenage mais il faut
attendre trois ans on ne voit pas
comment les choses pourraient se dénouer
sans qu'il y est un geste significatif
de la part du président vous savez la
politique le gouvernement des hommes ça
n'est ni une science ni une technique
c'est un art et la figure du l'éléphant
dans le magasin de porcelaine si elle
donne l'impression que l'éléphant a une
grande force
elle ne va pas résoudre la question de
savoir comment on va dîner et là on voit
que la transit dans ce qui a été opposé
aux divers grévistes et où diverses
professions a conduit par exemple
aujourd'hui les personnels des
transports publics à suspendre leur
grève après 45 jours
l'élément qui avait justifié sa était la
suspension de l'âge pivot à 64 ans et on
annonce aujourd'hui que l'âge des
équilibres qui le remplace est à 65 ans
c'est une façon d'armes est une sorte de
dispositifs parce que nous sommes en
france qui est un pays éruptif dont on
voit mal comment il ne va pas surgir par
pousser un peu comme la vapeur sort
d'une marmite
chaque fois que le coup lève le
couvercle se soulève la vapeur va sortir
chaque fois que le président va sortir
et on peut penser que le sentiment que
45 jours de grève n'ont pas même obtenu
une forme de négociations vont donner le
sentiment à des minorités agissantes que
seule une action violente va pouvoir
faire bouger les lignes
vous êtes une minorité il s'agit de cela
on a vu la tentative d'intrusion dans un
théâtre parisien où emmanuel macron
assister à une pièce ce début d'incendié
face au saccage en tout cas de la
brasserie la rotonde quelle est votre
analyse
la grève se murant violence et la suite
entre guillemets logique
vous savez dans une société quand le
volume global des tensions est très
élevé ou trop élevés comme il l'est
aujourd'hui on a toujours à un moment
une plaque sensible
un groupe de gens qui se trouve placée à
un endroit particulier qui ressent un
peu plus la violence de la situation et
qui va s'exprimer d'une manière violente
de façon inattendue et imprévisible
c'est ça la grande difficulté c'est le
caractère imprévisible et inattendu de
bouffées de violence qui peuvent
survenir quand une société atteint un
degré de pression très élevé et après 45
jours de grève sont négociations sans
succès avec un durcissement même de la
position officielle de l'exécutif on on
est dans les conditions qui favorisent
ces explosions c'est surgissement on
peut penser que jusqu'à la fin de son
quinquennat
emmanuel macron aura des difficultés
chaque fois qu'il aura sorti il n'ya pas
qu'emmanuel macro et aussi la cfdt qui
est la cible de quelques violences
nouvelle intrusion aujourd'hui au siège
de la cgt menée par une quinzaine de
personnes encagoulées qui ont coupé
l'électricité pendant quelques minutes
une action d'ailleurs revendiquée par
les syndicats cgt énergie l'île de
france est ce que la violence est
devenue une forme d'action de mode
d'action normale entre guillemets
banalisée dans notre société aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on exagère cgc ses affaires
quelques militants d'un autre syndicat
on dans un syndicat pour dire leur
protestation ou ne pas très bien on va
et ils n'ont pas détruit
ils font pas cassé ils ont arraché ni
les mains ni les yeux on est en face de
quelque chose qui n'est pas de
violence à force ouverte alors que on
peut se trouver dans les mois qui
viennent face à des actions à force
ouverte et qui ne viseront pas la cfdt
je crois vous pensez que la situation va
aller de mal en pis ça va empirer
or vous jusqu'où il n' est que s'il n'y
a pas quelque chose qui soit ressentie
par la majorité de la population qui a
soutenu le mouvement gréviste et qui a
pensé pour 75 % d'entre elles qu'il
fallait que le gouvernement modifie sa
copie s'il n'y a pas une forme de
réponse à ces 75 % de gens on peut
penser que la tension ne fera pas porté
par les 75% mais elle sera portée par
des secteurs plus restreint mais
cependant suffisamment large pour que
toute sortie à quelque moment que ce
soit se heurte à ces incidents
on peut imaginer que l'exécutif a le
raisonnement que la montée aux extrêmes
permet de mettre en scène le duel
habituel qui rend invincible l'opposant
de marine le pen
ça n'est pas si simple et ce serait un
calcul erroné que de jouer la politique
du pire comme il semble qu'à l'heure
actuelle les stratèges de l'élysée ait
choisi de le faire pour vous c'est une
vraie ce trajet stratégie de la part du
gouvernement ce qui est en train de
passer ce n'est pas tout simplement de
l'improvisation et voilà une manière de
mener notamment cette réforme des
retraites de manière improvisée et non
maîtrisée
c'est une stratégie voulue de jouer le
pourrissement de jouer cette violence
qui manque finalement et de la
maintenance si j'ose dire
on peut penser qu'il y avait au départ
beaucoup d'approximations avec le fait
qu'on change le responsable du dossier
en cours de route que les projections et
embêté par quelques affirmations de la
voir voilà que les projections n'avait
pas été fait
emmanuel macron s'est exprimé en disant
que jamais une accepterait d'âge pivot
le premier ministre a présenté un âge
pivot à 64 ans puis a retiré l'âge pivot
de 64 ans pour en remettra 1 à 65 ans de
ce point de vue on n'a pas l'habitude
sous la vème république de cet aspect
brouillon de l'exécutif mais de l'autre
côté on voit bien qu'il y à cette
tentation dans une partie
ceux qui sont aux affaires de penser que
la politique de la tension va permettre
de garantir un second quinquennat
je ne le crois pas je crois qu'elle va
garantir que la tension va s'affirmer
s'affermir et au total augmenté le degré
de violence dans une société c'est
toujours un risque parce qu'on ne sait
jamais comment revenir en arrière
vous êtes un fin connaisseur de la vie
politique et de l'histoire de la vie
politique française
est ce que finalement cette situation on
l'a déjà connu
non même en mai 68 avec le charles de
gaulle il n'était pas attaqué de la
sorte le général de gaulle ne se
présentait pas comme ça d'abord son
premier ministre georges pompidou
dès qu'il est rentré de roumanie où il
était temps en voyage officiel à faire
rouvrir la sorbonne a donné une série de
concessions aux étudiants mais c'était
trop tard
un certain nombre de salariés s'étaient
eux-mêmes mis en grève sur d'autres
thèmes et d'autres sujets immédiatement
des négociations ont été ouvertes
le smic a été montée de 370 à 600 francs
c'est à dire une hausse extraordinaire
il a été décidé une hausse générale des
salaires de 10%
donc c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
significatif dans les résultats d'une
part et d'autre part une négociation
était engagé dès le départ
là nous n'avons jamais eu de
négociations les événements de mai 68 il
démarre vers le
huit ou neuf mais il se termine autour
du 1er ou 2 juin nous voyons là que du
sun décembre au 20 janvier
c'est beaucoup plus long que mai 68
merci beaucoup gide casanova d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france sans
avoir à porter votre analyse
kuala lumpur renvoi 150 conteneurs de
déchets illégaux vers leur capital vers
les capitales occidentales concernées
paris londres ou encore washington la
malaisie refuse de devenir je cite la
décharge des pays développés florian
lambert la malaisie capitale mondiale du
déchet 150 conteneurs de déchets
plastiques illégaux ont été renvoyés de
malaisie vers leur pays d'origine
43 concerne la france les autorités de
ce pays d'asie du sud est ont affirmé
qu'elles ne voulaient pas que leur
territoire devienne une décharge pour
les pays développés
mais la ministre malaisienne de
l'environnement liés aux been souhaite
collaborer avec les pays concernés pour
régler ce conflit notamment les états
unis à ce jour le gouvernement de la
malaisie a renvoyé 150 conteneurs de
plastique des déchets plastiques
illégaux contenant quelques 3737 tonnes
grâce à notre inspection dans les paréos
données du département royal des douanes
malaisienne la plupart des conteneurs
sont exportés des pays développés
notamment la france le royaume-uni les
etats-unis et le canada l'espagne et le
japon
celui qui doit être renvoyée vient des
états unis
nous en avons encore 60 sur son disque
qui viennent des états unis
nous continuerons donc à travailler avec
le gouvernement américain les organismes
locaux compétents aux états unis pour
nous assurer que nous les renverrons le
marché mondial du recyclage a connu un
bouleversement majeur depuis la décision
en 2018 de la chine de cesser
l'importation de déchets plastiques
de nombreuses entreprises chinoises de
recyclage ont été délocalisées
malaisie entraînant un afflux de déchets
souvent illégales plusieurs pays d'asie
du sud-est ont pratiqué la même
politique ces derniers mois l'indonésie
a également expédié plusieurs centaines
de conteneurs vers leur pays d'origine
en juin dernier le canada avait rapatrié
plusieurs tonnes de déchets entreposés
aux philippines durant plusieurs années
un contentieux qui avait provoqué une
longue crise diplomatique entre les deux
pays et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis davos en suisse avec paul
rose patron de l'expédition national
geographic pristine 6 c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir par rose merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors la
malaisie qui renvoie 1 150 conteneurs de
déchets plastiques illégaux vers leur
pays d'origine dont 1,43 d'ailleurs vers
la france votre réaction pollueur payeur
finalement c'est bien fait c'était la
bonne réplique
je pense que cela doit être une bonne
nouvelle parce que j'ai toujours été
très occupée par le fait que nous
exportons nos déchets vers des pays en
développement des pays asiatiques
il est moins cher de les traiter ou de
les abandonner et je n'aime pas cela
c'est comme sur nous prenions ces
déchets et une vision que c'est loin des
yeux loin du coeur
une fois que c'est parti on n'a plus
besoin d'y penser
on se décharge de toute responsabilité
je suis très heureux que ces pays
commencent à renvoyer ces matériaux ou
vers leur pays d'origine là où ils ont
été utilisés au produit nous commençons
à développer un véritable sens de nos
responsabilités alors c'est vrai qu'en
tout cas cette opération entre
guillemets si on peut appeler ça comme
ça
elle mérite peut-être pour ceux qui
l'ignoré de connaître maintenant ce
procédé ces pays qui envoient les
déchets dans les pays d'asie du sud est
jusqu'ici commençaient dernier les
traités t-il ces déchets une fois qu'ils
reçoivent déchets jusqu'au milieu de
l'année dernière lorsque la loi a changé
il ya une grande décision à genève cette
décision était que les un pays pouvait
mettre en place un consentement de la
formation prioritaire il pouvait refuser
ceux qui n'avaient pas accepté
explicitement de traiter mais l'été
dernier des pays ont pu dire très bien
nous recycleront 20 conteneurs de p&t
mais avant cela les conteneurs pouvait
être plein de toutes sortes de déchets
intraitable et parfois essayé de les
transformer de les recycler d'autrefois
les abandonner tout simplement et cela
causait des images horribles ces
matériaux été rejetées dans des charges
dans une récession ou dans les rivières
et dans le même temps la france le
canada
pied en éventail ceara très bien traiter
ses déchets des qualités très
différentes
depuis cette décision prise à genève
l'été dernier il ya eu un changement de
tout le système
alors en france à vous vous le lisiez 1
cc déchets sur onze mille deux cents
tonnes de plastique rejeter en mer
chaque année par notre pays 11% s'échoue
dans les fonds marins à notre pays qui
est plutôt un mauvais élève est ce que
ça veut dire que dans les pays
occidentalisés dont fait partie on ne
sait pas du tout traités les déchets ça
paraît incroyable
merci dans le 10 mai les chiffres sont
incroyables
je ne sourirai en 1951 et à l'époque il
n'y avait quasiment pas de place sur
terre c'est un matériau depuis l'année
2005 en 1951 jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous
avons produit plus de 300 350 mille
tonnes de plastique et très peu de ce
plastique a été recyclé ou et le reste
et bien les scientifiques estiment le
bio 100 millions de tonnes de plastique
se trouve dans les océans
donc si nous continuons à envoyer ses
déchets vers des pays lointains qui nous
les perdons de vue si nous devons le
garder alors cela permet d'avoir une
impulsion pour plusieurs un cycle âge
dernière j'ai visité une usine est
appelée à quoi filles reprennent tous
ses filets de pêche a récupéré dans la
mer et toutes sortes d'autres spastique
inavem je n'étais pas recyclés et se
transforme du milan et c'est très
recherché aujourd'hui donc nous trouvons
des solutions très intelligente et je
pense qu'en arrêtant d'ex
or they know plastique loin il reste
dans nos têtes et nous permet de trouver
de nouvelles solutions d'inventer une
nouvelle technologie pour les recycler
merci beaucoup pas la rose patron de
l'expédition national geographic
christine 6 d'avoir été avec nous en
direct ce soir
vladimir poutine a soumis ce lundi au
parlement un ensemble d'amendements
constitutionnels
le président russe a présenté à les
changements proposés dans son discours
sur l'état de la nation destinée à
renforcer le rôle du parlement et à
consolider la démocratie
la chambre basse a reçu un projet de loi
sur les propositions constitutionnelles
du kremlin et a rapidement programme est
la première des trois lectures requises
pour jeudi
c'est très forme impliquera le transfert
de plus de pouvoir aux citoyens de notre
pays afin qu'ils puissent participer
plus efficacement au gouvernement en
s'attaquant aux problèmes auxquels notre
pays est confronté
en même temps le pouvoir présidentiel
reste fort basé sur les questions liées
à l'évaluation des activités des
fonctionnaires fédéraux du premier
ministre des responsables régionaux et
sur la possibilité de les révoquer le
premier ministre japonais vient de
réitérer sa volonté de parvenir à la
signature d'un traité paix avec la
russie cela suffira-t-il pour débloquer
une situation au point mort depuis
maintenant plus de 70 ans
éléments de réponse techniquement les
deux pays sont encore en guerre
en effet aucun traité de paix n'a encore
été signé entre le japon et la russie
depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale mais 2020 pourrait bien être la
bonne année pour le faire alors que le
monde s'apprête à commémorer les 75 ans
de la fin du conflit
en tout cas les deux parties semblent
déterminés à atteindre cet objectif
pas à pas les accords que nous avons
conclu avec le président russe vladimir
poutine sont mises en oeuvre nous allons
accélérer les pourparlers sur la base de
la déclaration commune de 1956 résoudre
le conflit territorial est signé un
traité de paix c'est la direction dans
laquelle nous allons sans aucune
hésitation
je suis pleinement déterminés à
atteindre cet objectif avec le président
vladimir poutine
nous avons une relation de confiance
nous discutons de tout cela en détail et
honnêtement les uns avec les autres
existe-t-il une solution à l'heure
actuelle pas encore oui qu'est-ce qui
est le plus important est la chose la
plus importante est que nous voulons la
trouver cette solution
cela peut être très différents comme je
vais une fois et mes amis japonais ont
apprécié j'ai dit que ce devrait être ic
i walk et c'est à dire égalité dans la
terminologie du judo mais plusieurs
questions devront être réglés avant d'y
parvenir
tout d'abord il à ce différend
territorial qui empoisonne les relations
russo japonaises depuis toutes ces
années
les kouriles il s'agit d'un archipel de
quatre îles qui se situent toutes au
nord du japon
peuplées de russes depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale un accord signé
entre l'urss et le japon en 1956
mentionne la possible rétrocession à
tokyo de deux de ces quatre îles après
la signature d'un traité de paix un
accord qui a été maintes fois utilisé
comme base de discussion dans les années
90 sans jamais être appliquée au
quotidien cela se traduit par des heures
en mer ou les gardes-côtes de chaque
pays se regardent en chiens de faïence
mais ce n'est pas tout la présence de
nombreuses base militaire américaine sur
l'archipel nippon et le possible
déploiement de missiles à moyenne portée
sur celui ci inquiète moscou au plus
haut point
ce n'est pas nous qui avons dit que les
etats-unis négocient avec le japon le
déploiement de missiles à moyenne portée
cela a été exprimé par vous sur la base
de vos sources
de source américaine comment ignorer
cela en ce qui concerne la question des
îles
quelle garantie avons nous que demain il
n'y aura pas de nouveau système de
missiles américains sur ces îles où sont
ces garanties
tokyo est en effet un allié important de
washington dans cette partie de l'asie
et les états unis entendent contenir la
menace potentielle de la corée du nord
est de la chine
en renforçant leur alliance avec le
japon communiqué du président à
l'occasion du 60e anniversaire du traité
de coopération et de sécurité mutuelle
ans
les états unis et le japon la solide
alliance entre nos deux grandes nations
a été essentielle à la paix à la
sécurité et à la prospérité des états
unis du japon et de la région indo
pacifique et du monde entier
alors que l'environnement sécuritaire
continue d'évoluer et que de nouveaux
défis surgissent
il est essentiel que notre alliance se
renforce et s'approfondissent davantage
la volonté de parvenir à la signature
d'un traité de paix entre le japon la
russie existe aujourd'hui peut être plus
que jamais auparavant
mais il reste de nombreux obstacles à
surmonter et de compromis à trouver de
part et d'autre avant d'arriver à une
issue positive dans quelques instants
rester avec nous notre débat sur le
maintien de l'ordre en france face à la
multiplication des accusations de
violences policières lors des
manifestations l'exécutif change de
temps emmanuel macron demandent des
propositions pour améliorer la
déontologie des forces de l'anp pts ont
encore manifesté en toute sécurité en
france nous en débattrons avec nos
invités
[Musique]
arrimé des pays africains à l'euro c'est
une évidence bêtise la france a intérêt
à maintenir des français parce que selon
le crr instruments qu'ils ont la
protection de ses intérêts économiques
en effet l'écho c'est quelque chose qui
était fait entre pays africains et sur
lequel la france et l'europe avait pas
grand chose à dire en question d'adapter
les fixes avec non mais c'est est ce que
c'est la même monnaie prochain le sujet
aujourd'hui en afrique c'est pas d'avoir
une inflation à 2%
ces espèces de critères qu'on impose
alors c'est des critères de qui a entre
guillemets d'économies matures à des
économies qui sont en développement
studio
ces sentiments que que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes qui poussent le fait de
vivre avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
comme une machine un organisme pour fait
partie de celles de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps quand vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces genres de projets qui se fait pas
tout seul dans son coin on est dans un
truc vraiment de coopération de partage
de partage
[Applaudissements]
je vis dans cet environnement depuis ma
naissance je veux voir quelque chose qui
est uniquement à moi un espace kim
appartiendrait à moi tout seul tout
d'abord il a dit je ne veux plus aller à
l'école c'est comme ça que ça a commencé
les mondes beaucoup c'est un problème
typiquement japonais profondément ancré
dans notre culture et notre société on
le retrouve surtout chez les jeunes
japonais j'ai même l'impression d'être
aimé par qui que ce soit je suis jamais
senti aimé la manière
[Musique]
merci de rejoindre 21h30 heure française
à mon double comité d'accueil hostile
pour emmanuel macron le président a
visité ce matin une usine symboles de
l'activité française
cet après midi donc à versailles face à
200 patrons étrangers rendez vous lors
desquelles il a été reçu par des
manifestants opposés à la réforme des
retraites
les violences policières de ce week-end
depuis plusieurs mois des violences ont
émaillé les manifestations de gilet
jaune la mobilisation contre la réforme
des retraites pour quelles suites
judiciaires ont fait le point tout de
suite en images avec leila sarah fain
[Rires]
[Musique]
et pour débattre de ces violences la
question de savoir est ce qu'on peut
aujourd'hui manifester en france sans
danger est ce que c'est toujours
possible c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre nous
sommes avec didier maïsto président de
sud radio
bonsoir didier maïsto merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france à ses côtés
jean sébastien ferjou fondateur
d'atlantico merci à vous d'être là
également un week end à nouveau marquée
par plusieurs violence on en parlera que
ce soit du côté voilà de l'exécutif
emmanuel macron pris pour cible du côté
également des manifestants de la police
un manifestant frapper au sol par un
policier samedi lors d'une manifestation
parisienne de gilet jaune il sera jugé
ultérieurement pour violences sur des
policiers
les policiers eux mêmes portent plainte
ce qu'il est toujours possible didier
maïsto avons l'honneur vous avez suivi
toutes ces manifestations depuis le
début est ce qu'il est toujours possible
de manifester sans danger dans notre
pays aujourd'hui
malheureusement la réponse est dans la
question on voit que ça devient de plus
en plus difficile
on voit qu'il ya une escalade de la
violence
on l'a connu avec les gilet jaune parce
que on a vu au bout de assez vite
d'ailleurs dès l'acte 2 de l'acte iii
qui atteint son paroxysme et puis après
cette violence a été instrumentalisé par
le pouvoir au plus qu'à l'acte iii
l'acte iii ils ont été dépassés ensuite
ils ont essayé de de l'instrumentaliser
en désignant les manifestants comme
étant eux mêmes des gens violents
factieux séditieux assoiffés de sang et
demi de la république et de la france
homophobe raciste antisémite j'en passe
et des meilleurs et donc sa stratégie de
la tension a continué ça s'est poursuivi
avec les grèves avec les grévistes
hélas la france remarque aujourd'hui que
c'est pas simplement dévolu au gilet
jaune un traitement spécial mais qu'en
fait tout mouvement de manifestations
toute contestation l'a vu aujourd'hui
et ce matin avec les avocats des gardes
à vue arbitraire des arrestations des
interpellations
il devient très difficile dans notre
pays de manifester pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement ce régime
semeta un secret pour personne ne
tirerai l'hymne vous l'appelez basse et
un régime c'est un régime qui ne tient
plus que par la police puisque il ya une
absence de discussion il ya un
malentendu profond entre le peuple et
ses représentants désignés ou appelons
les les représentants est donc
aujourd'hui quand vous avez comme ça un
exécutif qui ne tient que par les forces
de l'ordre avec une stratégie de la
tension ça ne peut que mal se finir donc
il est urgent effectivement que le
président la république prenne une
décision politique dissolution
référendum certains disent démission
n'aurait pas jusque là mais une décision
politique parce qu'on voit semaine après
semaine quand on quand on est au coeur
des manifs et effectivement je filme
depuis un an que il ya une escalade de
la violence que que les manifestations
soient déclarés pas déclaré on a
toujours la même stratégie du nas âge du
tabassage est effectivement aussi des
manifestants il faut pas l'ignorer qui
se radicalise
jean sébastien ferjou déjà sur le
diagnostic on va rentrer un peu plus
dans les détails est prêt mais sur le
diagnostic de votre voisin je crois
qu'il ya incontestablement une stratégie
de la tension on a près à la question
première que vous poser est ce qu'on
peut manifester sont mangés dans ce pays
ça dépend des manifestations enfin plus
exactement ça dépend de la cause
exactement les démarches pour le canada
mais une fête contre l'islamophobie
pardon n'a pas été entachée de violences
non plus mais c'est vrai que
incontestablement il ya une stratégie de
la tension après peut-être là où je
mettrais un bémol par rapport à la
vision quant à didier maïsto c'est que
ce n'est pas ce gouvernement là qu'a
inventé la violence ni la violence des
manifestations ni peut-être la violence
politique
le climat de violence politique qui
existe dans ce pays je pense que les
démocraties occidentales dans leur
ensemble vivent une crise de défiance et
que le vrai échec de macron et que sa
promesse était de réenchanter en quelque
sorte justement enfin en tout cas de
nous faire sortir collectivement de
cette crise de défiance très clairement
il n'y est pas parvenu il n'est pas le
seul à être responsables de cet état de
fait parce que je pense qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment d'opposition qui arrive à
s'imposer à se dégager de ses passions
dissolution nous permettrait peut-être
aurait-il intérêt à le faire
politiquement ça c'est une autre
question
mais je vois personne en l'état qui est
de majorité je pense que ce n'est pas
négligeable parce que la crise elle se
construit aussi par rapport à ça le
monopole de la violence légitime encore
faut-il que vous soyez perçu comme
légitime et on voit que de plus en plus
les gouvernements ne sont plus perçus
comme légitime et que en face il ya des
gens alors on peut ne pas être perçu
comme légitime par des manifestants qui
resterait parfaitement pacifique au
moment de la manif pour tous notamment
des manifestants étaient extrêmement
pacifique ce qui n'a pas empêché
d'ailleurs et c'est un nouveau
quinquennat une répression n'ont pas
vraiment policière en tout cas
judiciaire assez sévères vis-à-vis des
veilleurs notamment comme je le disais
ça s'inscrit dans une histoire mais là
où il ya une véritable responsabilité là
dessus je crois vraiment didier maïsto
c'est sur ce mélange de stratégie et
probablement d'incompétence vous savez
la vieille phrase quand on vous propose
une explication complotistes entre pas
entre le complotisme et l'incompétence
privilégiez toujours en premier lieu l
incompétence je pense qu'il ya de ça
cela que le préfet de police précédent
ne savait pas bien géré je pense que
monsieur castetner comme ministre de
l'intérieur ne sait pas bien c'est un
mélange de stratégie parce que ils ont
joué à la tension pour que ce soit
clivant et pour que l'opinion se
retourne en leur faveur
enfin en la faveur du gouvernement à
force de voir ces violences là ça un peu
marcher d'ailleurs au moment
des gilets jaunes mais il ya aussi un
vrai un vrai problème en matière de
maintien de l'ordre en cette ère de
maîtrise de maintien de l'ordre
et en plus puisque ces mouvements durs
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de policiers qui
malheureusement sont envoyés sur la
ligne de front en quelque sorte en
n'étant pas assez formés et mal encadrée
et donc c'est un espèce de cocktail
explosif
voilà effectivement le bémol étant
peut-être gouvernement des panneaux
siècle après son audition eux mêmes qui
se succèdent sur ce plateau aurait
expliqué que la formation est très
compliqué ils n'ont pas eu le temps
d'être formés et c'est majeur en matière
de maintenance est absolument majeur les
gens ne se rendent pas compte que c'est
l'impression que être policier sait
rester là non savoir ne pas réagir enfin
ça va enfin même les tactiques
d'occupation d'une rue ou pour empêcher
la progression d'un mouvement
c'est absolument c'est absolument majeur
effectivement il ya des policiers qui ne
sont pas formés
aujourd'hui marine le pen et o'neal et
fort du parti socialiste demande
clairement le départ du préfet l'helmand
le préfet de police de paris est ce que
c'est l'une des solutions à l'heure des
mea culpa de christophe castaner d'un
côté d'emmanuel micron qui commet qui
parle de déontologie bien soyons clairs
on peut toujours s'attaquer aux
lampistes en réalité effectivement quand
il y avait l'ancien préfet de police de
paris où il avait été jugé par par ce
pouvoir trop mou trop laxiste et trop
permissive et quand il avait émis des
petits bémols justement quant à
l'utilisation des lbc par exemple ou
dans la stratégie de maintien de l'ordre
c'était un secret là aussi de
polichinelle un mois avant pendant les
milieux informés on savait que monsieur
l'allemand allait être nommé
bon donc aujourd'hui monsieur l'allemand
il applique la politique qui lui et qui
lui est dicté par l'elysée est
d'ailleurs dans ses voeux à la presse
est ce qu a dit tout à fait manuel
macron il a dit qu'il ne faiblit pas
face
et puis tout où tous les éléments de
langage vous l'avez vu encore tout ce
week-end de que ce soit des ministres et
secrétaires d'état des députés de la
république en marche tout le monde va
dans ce sens alors il pousse des cris
d'orfraie quand vous avez 20 personnes
qui rentrent en chantant dans la seine
et s est pas bien effectivement
d'envahir un local syndical
enfin
il ya quand même eu leur aplomb
rappelons le grâce à l'excellent travail
de david dufresne 900 signalements de
décès vingt-cinq personnes éborgné cinq
mains arrachées 385e blessures à la tête
c'est pas du détail et qu'encore une
fois moins inquiété dans mon adn c'était
plutôt au départ d'être pour les forces
de l'ordre légal nice etc
j'ai voulu aller voir venividivici j'ai
vu effectivement je ne peux que j'ai
vaincu j'ai vaincu en tout cas la langue
de bois c'est déjà très intéressant ce
que vous nous dites parce que vu de
l'extérieur c'est vrai qu'on peut se
poser la question on lit aussi quelques
papiers parce qu'on parle toujours de
l'instrumentalisation voilà du pouvoir
mais certains de voix critiques aussi
difficile à dire la part de la gauche
radicale de ces manifestions qui
deviennent violents ça vous le niez
aujourd'hui vous qui connaissez bien le
terrain est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous excluez totalement parce que
c'est aussi une partie de la france qui
pense ça aussi de surveillance quand on
allume son poste de télé qu'on voit ces
violences soyons très clairs les linda
kebab n'est pas spécialement connu pour
être une spécialiste syndicat policier
laxistes ou d'extrême gauche
le dit elle-même les 10 black block y
aurait beaucoup à dire
on a déjà fait des émissions sur ce
sujet je vais pas ouvrir tous les
tiroirs les 10 black blocks les hommes
en noir en tout cas qui sème le bazar
dans les manifestations sont
parfaitement identifiés par les forces
de l'ordre et par les autorités on sait
qu'ils y sont etc
on les laisse faire on ouvre grand les
vannes d'une manifestation on les
referment et on laisse les éléments les
plus radicaux s'agiter ça tue les
mouvements sociaux ça pense le pouvoir
pense-t-il ça discrédite les mouvements
sociaux et pour partie c'est réussi sauf
que finalement par capillarité les gens
qui voient non seulement ça mais qui
voit aussi des buts il ait des blessés
le fait de deux
déclarer une manifestation ne pas
déclarer on arrive toujours au même
résultat
et quand vous avez les éléments les plus
radicaux qui sont pas du tout ni des
gilet jaune ni des grévistes mais qui
sont là et jean sébastien ferjou et aux
ondes le rappeler ça ne date pas de
gilet jaune on a déjà vu ça lors de la
loi travaille par exemple avec monsieur
valls avec des gens qui venaient on sait
pas d'où ni comment et avec une
répression très sévère donc ces gens là
ils sont laissés bien tranquillement
donc effectivement il y a des éléments
radicaux on les connaît on les laisse
faire on pour courir cette stratégie du
pourrissement
les mouvements sociaux et pour permettre
derrière de réprimer durement 10 envoyée
il ya mélenchon il ya l'extrême gauche à
l'égout schiste mais qui peut être dû en
sébastien lesage anglais avec cette
analyse sur la question que vous posez
sur le préfet est choqué par sa base à
l'époque je suis assez d'accord avec ce
que vous disiez c'est pas lui qui est le
plus responsable
c'est quand même lui la cheville
ouvrière des stratégies qui peuvent être
mises en oeuvre la stratégie la
souricière sur la place d'italie ont dû
retour des gilets jaunes je pensais
quand même particulièrement contestable
mais moi j'avais été choqué par sa
phrase nous ne sommes pas dans le même
camp en s'adressant à une manifestante
sous je ne pense pas que ce soit
éventuellement un ministre aurait pu
peut-être le dire parce qu'il ya un côté
politique à un ministre peut se
présenter ou se représenter devant une
élection sa responsabilité peut être
engagée au parlement de la part d'un
haut fonctionnaire de l'état je trouve
ça choquant de dire nous ne sommes pas
dans le même camp le préfet l'allemand
n'a pas être dans un camp il a assuré le
maintien de l'ordre sans a priori
prendre parti d'ailleurs dans le conflit
politique qui se joue derrière ses
enjeux ses enjeux de maintien de l'ordre
maintenant sur le pourrissement oui mais
là où je pense c'est à la fin ça marche
et ça ne marche pas c'est à dire que je
pense que ça ne fait qu'accentuer la
crise de défiance c'est à dire que oui
peut-être ça déconsidère certains
mouvements sociaux et qu'il faut dire le
cherchant quelque soit parce que c'est
quand même une stratégie du clivage la
violence je parle pas des manifestants
l'emmena mais on l'a vu encore la
dernière manifestation enfin celle du
jeudi d'il ya dix jours rue de la
pépinière il ya en quelque sorte de
manifestation et le cortège bien
organisés et puis un prêt cortège où là
il ya énormément de violence
et c'est une stratégie assez classique
de criblage pour justement forcer les
gens à choisir un camp le problème c'est
que en général les gouvernements
essaient plutôt deux
faire baisser la tension d'un cran et
que celui-là rentrer dans la danse
et donc c'est une espèce de redoutables
valse à deux en quelque sorte chacun
jouant ce côté c'est la stratégie des
terroristes alors bien sûr il s'agit pas
de la même violence mais vous savez
c'est de dire 'voilà choisi cinq ans
parce que de toute façon ce qu'on vous
mais souvenez n'est pas acceptable je
pense que pour la majorité des français
choisissent ni l'un ni l'autre
ils sont juste effaré par ce qui se
passe parce qu'ils soutiennent les
policiers au sens où personne n'a envie
d'un pays où il n'y aurait plus de
maintien de l'ordre il y aurait plus de
policiers mais j'ai quand même apprécié
d'ailleurs montre avec quelqu'un sur
atlantico qui s'appelle gicle un café
mais je crois vous en avez fait beaucoup
aussi didier qui a fait toutes les
manifestations toutes les manifestations
des gilets jaunes et la plupart des
manifestations liées au conflit sur les
retraites
il ya incontestablement des violences
policières incontestablement mais je
crois qu personnes ont dit qu'il ya
quand même aussi en face de la part
d'une minorité de manifestantes une
énorme violences malgré tout les ans
quand ça se joue sur des policiers qui
sont mal formés qui ont des instructions
politique peu claires justement parce
que ça n'est pas toujours évident de
savoir ce qu'ils sont sans fin ce qu'on
attend d'eux bien évidemment on
attendait de maintien de l'ordre une
fois que vous avez dit ça ça ne dit pas
est ce qu'on laisse les gens descendent
les champs-elysées est ce qu'on les
laisse aller à tel endroit ou pas voilà
il ya toutes ces responsabilités là que
je dise cumulé je crois qu'ils
alimentent le climat profondément
délétère qui sont justement lors de son
discours à la police nationale
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a rappelé l'importance
de l' usage proportionné de la force
l'usagé juste et proportionnée de la
force et ce qui sépare la démocratie de
l'arbitraire ce qui distingue l'ordre et
la brutalité
c'est le fondement aussi de notre
confiance avec les français c'est
l'honneur de la police qui est en jeu on
ne fait pas de croche pied à l'éthique
sauf à s'abaisser à abaisser la police à
l'ats christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur qui semble tenir malgré
toutes les polémiques
qu'est ce qui fait que christophe
castaner soit encore là n'diaye maisto
le problème de
ce gouvernement sans le vouloir lui
faire injure c'est que quand même comme
le disait tout à l'heure jean sébastien
il faut trouver des gens
il est assez faible techniquement je
dirais les personnalités qui ont cours
qui entoure emmanuel macron et gérard
collomb guépard qui ne brillent pas par
leur technicité leurs capacités leur
charisme sur le champ du régalien c'est
quand même assez assez c'est triste donc
qu'est ce qu'il a fait ce gouvernement
en fait caca fait emmanuel macron il a
pris un peu de l air un peu de paix est
finalement c'est un peu le fond de cuve
qu'il est allé chercher parce que allait
aller chercher monsieur castaner ou qui
était quatrième couteau au parti
socialiste ou d'autres je veux pas leur
faire injure
enfin il fallait faire le en même temps
il fallait faire la république en marche
et essayer d'avoir un peu de droite de
gauche à total on voit que nous avons
des gens complètement dépassés qui ne
sont pas à la hauteur de leurs fonctions
et d'ailleurs pour finir là-dessus on
parle beaucoup de techniques de maintien
de l'ordre etc
le problème c'est d'abord un problème
politique c'est à dire combien on fait
faire à la police la police à les former
ou mal formés d'ailleurs mais pour faire
du maintien de l'ordre
pas pour répondre à une politique ou à
essayer d'en l'imposer or aujourd'hui on
voit que la seule réponse que ce soit
aux avocats aux médecins vous le voyez
dans les hôpitaux dans les eaux
professeurs aux grévistes quels qu'ils
soient du service public du service
privé dans les écoles partout qu'est-ce
qu'on fait dès qu'il ya une contestation
d'envoi la police on met les gens en
garde à vue ou alors de façon préventive
on les met en prison les interroger le
lendemain puis on les fait partir sans
mal un rappel à la loi
c'est pour ça que je parle de régime on
est passé quand même dans autre chose
dans un régime
j'aime pas bien où je suis d'accord
c'est peut-être avec un certain nombre
de policiers
le terme notamment des d'alexandre
l'emploi de violences policières moi je
préfère parler de violence politique de
violence d'état parce qu'aujourd'hui
nous en sommes là et les policiers ne
sont que les instruments de cette
violence d'état et il ya beaucoup de
policiers
qui son gilet jaune je sais ça paraît
incongru aujourd'hui on en a eu sur ce
point je rencontre plein tous les jours
je pense que jean-sébastien aussi alors
il ya aussi les policiers qui sont pas
d'accord avec voilà la tête par dont la
stratégie du maintien de l'ordre à en
écouter un loïc travers secrétaire
national adjoint de la section
ile-de-france du syndicat de police
alliance
le vrai débat c'est qu'il y a une vraie
montée de violence que ce soit par le
biais ou de black blocks ou deux
personnes qui sont radicalisées ou des
personnes et biens qui simplement
viennent piller certains magasins qui
viennent se faire plaisir et bien ces
phénomènes la de bande ou pas d'ailleurs
que les policiers essaient d'enrayer
avec des techniques qui sont
effectivement extrêmement précises qui
sont pour le moment est clairement
techniquement et juridiquement adapté il
y à de nombreux propos depuis quelques
semaines qui dit ben voilà que la police
ne doit plus utiliser les lacrymogènes
elle doit plus utiliser la matraque
télescopique elop doit plus utilisé
l'étranglement
elle ne doit plus utiliser le placage
ventrale un moment il faut bien qu'ils
nous restent des techniques pour
interpeller les gens violents
on va pas finir en tutu avec une fleur à
la main pour interpeller des gens qui
s'en prennent à nos collègues et qui
n'ont qu'une envie de blesser gravement
voire de tuer jean sébastien ferjou
c'est vrai que ce policier il exprime
aussi la voie de la part d'une partie de
l'opinion française parce qu'on peut lui
répondre
moi je comprends parfaitement ce qu'il
est ce prix parce que je vous le disais
tout à l'heure c'est une partie qui se
joue à deux savent que je suis d'accord
avec ce que disait didier mesto sur la
stratégie à l'aune de mélange
d'incompétence technique ou de
compétences faible disons technique sur
les sujets liés au maintien de l'ordre
et de stratégie politique mais en face
il ya quand même des gens qui ne croient
pas à la démocratie représentative sûr
que les intrusions dans les locaux de la
cfdt
ou alors vouloir aller empêcher monsieur
mâcon ce pas tant leur empêchait la
halle au théâtre ça paraît un peu
ridicule comme ça mais enfin quand on
vit dans ce climat là la démocratie ne
soit plus aussi à des gens qui
contestent la légitimité de sa présence
maintenant je suis désolé malgré tout
monsieur macron et tellure à des
élections dans deux ans les gens qui ne
sont pas d'accord même ceux qui luttent
qui contestent le principe de la réforme
des retraites
comprendre ou pas c'est un autre sujet
mais enfin de 60 va s'appliquer dans
très longtemps il y aura des élections
bien avant ça s'ils sont persuadés de
détenir une majorité ils peuvent très
bien miser sur les élections suivant je
pense qu'elle ré une responsabilité
aussi
non pas nécessairement des gens qui sont
dans la rue
mais des responsables politiques parfois
qui soutiennent ce genre de mouvement et
qui en l'air de considérer qu'il est
normal de remettre en cause la
démocratie représentative ce n'est pas
parce que monsieur macron où son
gouvernement sont moins représentatifs
qu'on a connu enfin que ce qu'on a pu
connaître dans des périodes antérieures
mais tout simplement parce que je vous
disais c'est la crise de défiance
convient de toute façon demain on fait
des élections personne ne sera floué
représentatif parce que la société est
fracturée et dans de toute façon ceux
qui les remplaceront aussi tenté il
existe une alternative politique dans
des élections mm macro mais ça fait un
peu partie du problème aussi seraient
eux aussi rassemblés ont très mal perçu
moi je crois pas qu'il faille y jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain ans je crois à
la démocratie représentative et il faut
savoir en défendre les principes
maintenant quand la police est la seule
arme qui reste à un gouvernement pour se
maintenir au pouvoir même si c'est un
peu abusé parce qu'on n'est plus dans
cette situation là on a été probablement
un peu pendant l'été dernier c'est
complexe et je trouve particulier de la
part du président de la république ou du
ministre de l'intérieur de se situer un
peu en observateur extérieur quand ils
font des commentaires sur l'emploi de la
violence par la police il me semble que
quand même des éléments dont nous
disposons tous ils les ont depuis
maintenant des mois et que arrivé comme
ça en jambes quand même c'est un peu
dommage voilà je trouve ce ne sont pas
des commentateurs ils sont responsables
de la politique est mise en oeuvre et le
cas échéant ils sont responsables je
parle pas de lan policiers qui pète les
plombs dans un instant d'énervement je
sais pas quoi ou bref mais ils sont
responsables
globalement du climat de violence qui
s'est passé dans ces manifestations
didier maïsto connaît votre avis
effectivement sur ces violences
policières mais sur ce que disait jean
sébastien ferjou sur voilà cette partie
peut-être des manifestants qui remettent
en cause la démocratie représentative
est ce qu'il est normal effectivement
d'aller si l'air président de la
république et au théâtre un samedi soir
avec son épouse
est ce que ça vous semble légitime
je sais pas si c'est
jti mot normal je sais pas ce qu'est la
norme en tout cas ce que je sais c'est
que ce président ce président a écrit un
livre intitulé révolution
il a dit lui-même c'est moi le
responsable qui viennent me chercher
on l'a dit lui-même les gens qui ne sont
rien les illettrés les factieux les
séditieux
ça fait beaucoup quand on est président
de la république on doit pas opposer les
uns aux autres une catégorie de français
à une autre et donc si vous voulez au
bout d'un an ou de 14 mois comme rien ne
se passe les gens lui disent chiche on
va venir te chercher je dis pas que
c'est bien sauf que c'est pas je dis pas
que les français ce sont des gens les
manifestants en vérité là les normes et
les manifestants on me disait les gens
mais juste sonar mais les français n'y a
quand même remis chaque fois un euro
dans la machine
il a un petit peu excité pensant être
l'éviter un peut être un peu au dessus
de ça en disant vous allez voir moi je
suis assez d'accord avec vous de jeudi
sera finalement la principes de la
démocratie ne se divise pas c'est
toujours sur les mauvais exemples c'est
comme la liberté d'expression il faut se
battre pour la liberté d'expression
quand quelqu'un dit quelque chose de
choquant
j'ai de la mer et les mandats il faut
défendre les institutions y compris
quand celui qui en est le titulaire
comme les jeunes macron mais pas
nécessairement à la hauteur de la
finance je suis pleinement et non mais
c'est simplement pour répondre ça c'est
vrai en théorie je dis simplement que
c'est un président qui est disruptif
comme il l'a voulu ainsi lui il a dit le
medad l'alimentent le fait même qu'il
était révolutionnaire etc
il ne cesse d'attaquer les gens si on
reprend le florilège de toutes ces
petites phrases de lui et de 5,2 de tout
son gouvernement etc
quand vous avez la porte parole qui dit
je souhaite bonne chance aux grévistes
mois matin je prends ma voiture de
fonction etc etc
c'est quand même un moment le mépris si
vous voulez s'ajoutant au mépris
s'ajoutant aux dénis et s'ajoutant
finalement au mutisme absolu parce que
je rappelle que les gilet jaune dont
jamais été reçue d'une manière difficile
et mesure les 10 milliards il ya eu des
mesures tout de même sur les mesures à
mesure
les mesures budgétaires il faut regarder
le plan de financement de la sécurité
sociale
la mobilisation a un petit peu baissé à
ce moment là la moitié ok très bien ce
que je dis simplement c'est que là ce
président là s'est comporté d'une
manière quand même belliqueuse c'est un
belliciste c'est un combattant très bien
il en assume les conséquences je dis pas
que c'est bien mais dis pas que je suis
pas dans le drame dans un ordre moral
non mais de grâce il n'y a pas de
l'ingestion de politique parce que la
violence est un peu ce que j'ai pleuré
toute heure la violence vient aussi de
là la responsabilité elle est peut-être
celle de monsieur macron qui
effectivement a pu commettre un certain
nombre d'erreurs qu'il a lui-même
reconnu d'ailleurs je sais pas si elle
empêche vraiment de continuer à les
connaître
enfin bref il a semblé être conscient du
côté arrogant méprisant provocateur
qu'il pouvait avoir
mais dangereux démocratie il faut qu'il
ya une opposition qui se montre à la
hauteur et là le drame français à
l'heure actuelle c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de position qui parviennent
véritablement a structuré ou apparaître
une alternative crédible parce qu'il ya
des oppositions ont fait 9 actuellement
on a toujours marine le pen on peut
avoir les républicains qui reste le
premier parti d'opposition du pays si on
regarde le monde ait eu la france
insoumise d'autres mais ils n'arrivent
pas à formuler une réponse mm macro qui
sembleraient à tirer derrière elle une
majorité de français la violence ça
vient la violence vient aussi de là
parce que dans une démocratie quand la
démocratie paraît bloquée que certaines
catégories de population l'impression
qu'elles seront exclues du pouvoir de
toute façon parce que les élections
alors permettront jamais d'atteindre les
solutions qu'elle souhaite à ce moment
là il ya toujours de la violence qu'est
ce qui s'est exactement alors rapidement
il ya quand même un problème si jean
sébastien parler de démocratie
représentative qu'il faut respecter
évidemment il a été élu tout le monde le
respecte c'est légitime et je suis pas
un factieux très bien il faut quand même
se poser la question de la cette
représentativité de la démocratie qui
est quand même à l'agonie puisque je
rappelle que en nombre enfin en il a 25
ans il a fait 25 % des voix au premier
tour mais 18% blond inscrits c'est à
dire que sur 100 personnes
il ya 82 personnes qui n'ont pas voté
pour emmanuel macron mais c'est pas
propre à la nouvelle macro on l'a vécu
avec françois hollande
on l'a vécu avec jacques chirac et fière
de tout ce qui faisait encore moins
il ya une balkanisation une atomisation
total de la vie politique française
il n'y a pas de solution donc c'est pour
ça que s'est exprimée ou alors le aller
vers mettre le curseur je nie pas
complètement mais pousser le curseur
vers plus de démocratie participative
ont découvert un homme
l'initiative citoyenne et c'est que les
c'est ce que les gens reprennent un
petit peu en main leur souveraineté et
puissent avoir les manettes pas surtout
aimé avoir plus de référendum plus de
participation je pense qu'on peut
revivifiée revitaliser comme ça la
démocratie qu'est quand même il va
rester sur le à sémalens pour les
habitudes
merci dd mr merci jean sébastien ferjou
d'avoir été avec nous restez avec nous
dans quelques instants un point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
oui
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mari un
couple très fusionnelle à ce que vous
viviez un peu dans la peur avec tino
quai des menaces oui d intimidation
comme brûler les locaux oui mais un
assassinat vraiment jeune ans je pense
que j'y croyais pas ceux qui ont été
assassinés étaient les politiques du
journal il était l'âme de ce journal et
oui ils ont tué charlie je voulais pas
que tignes où ce soit une victime
je voulais pas que son nom soit associé
à 8 e-news la victime de charlie je
voulais que l'on se dise à tignes où le
grand dessinateur c'est ça qui est bien
avec un artiste c'est qu'un artiste tant
qu'on publie son travail l'artiste est
vivant
[Musique]
les news ne s'arrête jamais mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
yanni elle a parfois on n'a que des
éléphanteaux victimes de braconnage
particulièrement brutale car
malheureusement les bébés sont souvent
témoin non seulement du meurtre de leur
mère mais aussi la voix se faire
massacrer d'équipé nombreux check out
je crois que les éléphants sourient
c'est ce que je vois chez les petits
leurs expressions faciales change
et
[Musique]
cette histoire est étroitement liée à la
culture
c'est l'histoire d'une communauté
nollywood est un groupe de personnes qui
veulent vraiment raconter leur histoire
c'est comme sortir avec un homme marié
oui c'est comme de sortir avec un homme
marié tu dois le faire vite et pas cher
si tu le fais vite
cela signifie que ce n'est pas cher si
tu veux faire des affaires ou pas et
coupez coupez
[Musique]
le comité d'accueil hostile pour
emmanuel macron le président en visite
ce matin dans une usine de dunkerque
symbole de l'attractivité française est
en représentation cet après midi à
versailles face à 200 patrons étrangers
deux rendez vous lors desquelles il a
été reçu par des manifestants opposés à
la réforme des retraites
on ira comme nouvelle flambée de
violence trois manifestants ont été tués
et des dizaines de blessés lors
d'affrontements avec les forces de
sécurité
une escalade de tension qui intervient à
l'expiration du délai donné au
gouvernement par le mouvement de
contestation pour répondre à ces
revendications des routes toujours en
pleine déroute
réunion aujourd'hui autour du président
libanais des hauts responsables de la
sécurité en cause un week-end de
violences entre manifestants
antigouvernementaux et forces de l'ordre
bilan au moins 520 blessés
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france emmanuel macron
était en visite aujourd'hui à dunkerque
et versailles
l'occasion pour le chef de l'état de
défendre ses réformes sur l'emploi et
l'innovation à l'occasion de la journée
de suspense mais aussi l'occasion de
constater une nouvelle fois un accueil
hostile à son arrivée florent ou lambert
une journée mouvementée pour emmanuel
macron en visite ce lundi matin dans
l'usiné pharmaceutique astrazeneca
dunkerque
le chef de l'état défend ses réformes
sur l'emploi et l'innovation devant
quelques 300 employés du groupe anglo
suédois
mais à quelques mètres de l'usiné une
cinquantaine de manifestants cgt et une
dizaine d'avocats du barreau de
dunkerque sont présents et souhaite
interpeller le président contre le
projet de réforme des retraites
nous avons souhaité rencontrer
effectivement monsieur emmanuel macron
ou ses proches pour le sensibiliser à
notre interpellation
les avocats sont en grève depuis
maintenant 15 jours cette grève a été
reconduite de nouveau pendant une
semaine les avocats n'accepte pas la
réforme que l'on veut leur imposer en
termes de régimes de retraite il s'agit
en réalité et bien d'une manifestation
nationale et l'ensemble des barreaux de
france et de navarre sont actuellement
en grève pour et bien faire pression
pour le gouvernement auprès du
gouvernement pour pouvoir être
simplement entendus pour faire valoir
effectivement leurs observations il
fallait qu'on soit là
bien évidemment pour accueillir le
président des riches et lui faire savoir
qu'on était totalement déterminée sur le
dunkerquois comme comme ailleurs dans le
pays pour obtenir le retrait de cette
réforme comprend pas depuis plusieurs
semaines dans l'après midi emmanuel
macron seront un versailles afin de
rencontrer des patrons venus du monde
entier pour la troisième édition du
sommet tous friends
comprenez choisissez la france seulement
pendant ce temps là un cortège de plus
de 300 manifestants selon les
organisateurs étaient présents devant le
château de versailles
portant des slogans au vitriol contre le
chef de l'état venir en pleine
mobilisation sociale d'une ampleur
historique avec les 200 plus grands
patrons se pavaner dans un lieu qui est
quand même symbolique d'un régime qui
est pas celui de la république terre à
versailles bon je trouve ça changera
chez eux parce qu'ils se rendent compte
à quel point c'est ça une image assez
insupportable pour le reste du pays
il faut montrer au gouvernement qu'il
est nulle part chez lui aujourd'hui
quand on est quand tu vois là il est
accueilli comme ça enfin accueilli quand
il est attendu à la sortie du théâtre
par une foule
qu'ils aient envie de l'interpeller dû
poser des questions il se rend bien
compte que il est plus chez lui et nous
on est chez nous deux jours après sa
sortie mouvementée du théâtre des
bouffes du nord à paris
emmanuel macron a une nouvelle fois dû
sortir par la petite porte ce lundi
selon gilles casanova consultant en
stratégie et communication il y aurait
bien une solution radicale pour calmer
les esprits l'élection d'un nouveau
président serait quelque chose qui
stopperait cet engrenage mais il faut
attendre trois ans on ne voit pas
comment les choses pourraient se dénouer
sans qu'il y est un geste significatif
de la part du président
vous savez la politique le gouvernement
des hommes ce n'est ni une science ni
une technique c'est un art et la figure
du l'éléphant dans le magasin de
porcelaine si elle donne l'impression
que l'éléphant a une grande force
elle ne va pas résoudre la question de
savoir comment on va dîner et là on voit
que la transit dans ce qui a été opposé
aux divers grévistes et où diverses
professions a conduit par exemple
aujourd'hui les personnels des
transports publics à suspendre leur
grève après 45 jours
l'élément qui avait justifié sa était la
suspension de l'âge pivot à 64 ans et on
annonce aujourd'hui que l'âge déquilibre
qu'il remplace est à 65 ans c'est une
façon d'armes est une sorte de
dispositifs les avocats à dunkerque mais
également à paris aujourd'hui les robes
noires aux côtés des gilet jaune pour
manifester
à l'intérieur du tribunal de grande
instance de la capitale plusieurs
dizaines d'entre eux ont appelé
notamment à la démission des manuels
macron ils dénoncent la réforme des
retraites du gouvernement
et deux jours après l'acte 62 des gilet
jaune émaillés de heurts les violences
plus que jamais d'actualité
trois policiers dont l'auteur des coups
portent plainte contre le manifestant
molesté sebli à paris dans le même temps
une enquête administrative est ouverte
par l'igpn pour violences volontaires
par personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique selon le secrétaire général du
syndicat police alliance le militant
aurait proféré des propos haineux je
cite j'ai le sida tu vas crever fin de
citation et loïc travers secrétaire
national ile-de-france du syndicat
police alliance confirme les dires
écouter ces propos sont sont la finalité
est bien d'une série de violences qu'a
réalisé cette même personne contre
plusieurs policiers premièrement en
jetant divers projectiles et notamment
une bouteille en verre qui va éclater
sur un des collègues qui étaient dans le
dispositif
puis une seconde fois eh bien il va tout
simplement venir au contact des
policiers les frapper par derrière dans
le dos sur la tête alors même que ses
collègues étaient affairés à interpeller
une personne qui d'ailleurs avec les
coups qu'ils vont prendre bien vont
surtout penser à se protéger
ça va faire fuir d'ailleurs l'une des
personnes interpellées
et enfin cette même personne et bien
qu'ils commettaient ces exactions
parfaitement reconnue et bien est elle
même à son tour subi les assauts des des
policiers et va être effectivement
plaqué au sol et alors qu'un policier
est bien qui va s'approcher de lui pour
voir un petit peu ce qu'il a au niveau
du du cuir chevelu parce qu'il y avait
une plaie saignante non alors alliée à
la base pour l'aider et bien va prendre
trois crachats succès successifs
notamment avec du sang est effectivement
à l'occasion du 2ème crachats et bien il
va dire la phrase que vous avez
effectivement évoqué à savoir je le sida
tu vas crever depuis l'émergence du
mouvement des gilet jaune puis la
contestation du projet de réforme des
retraites le débat sur la violence des
forces de l'ordre dé relancer chaque
n pour quelles suites judiciaires ont
fait le point en images avec leïla
sarraf
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
[Rires]
[Musique]
et on écoute maintenant les réactions de
jean sébastien ferjou fondateur
d'atlantico et didier maïsto président
de sud radio tous deux présents ce soir
pour notre face à face on voit qu'il ya
une escalade de la violence
on l'a connu avec les gilet jaune parce
que on a vu au bout de assez vite
d'ailleurs dès l'acte 2 dès l'acte iii
qui atteint son paroxysme et puis après
cette violence a été instrumentalisé par
le pouvoir au plus qu'à l'acte iii
l'acte iii ils ont été dépassés ensuite
ils ont essayé de de l'instrumentaliser
en désignant les manifestants comme
étant eux mêmes des gens violents
factieux séditieux assoiffés de sang et
demi de la république et de la france
homophobe raciste antisémite j'en passe
et des meilleurs mais qu'en fait tout
mouvement de manifestations toute
contestation l'a vu aujourd'hui et ce
matin avec les avocats des gardes à vue
arbitraire des arrestations des
interpellations devient très difficile
dans notre pays de manifester je crois
qu'il ya incontestablement une stratégie
de la tension on a près à la question
première que vous poser est ce qu'on
peut manifester sans manger dans ce pays
ça dépend des manifestations enfin plus
exactement ça dépend de la cause
le buteur exemple exactement les
démarches pour le climat la
manifestation contre l'islamophobie
pardon n'a pas été entachée de violences
non plus mais c'est vrai qu
incontestablement il ya une stratégie de
la tension après peut-être là où je
mettrais un bémol par rapport à la
vision quant à didier maïsto c'est que
ce n'est pas ce gouvernement là qu'a
inventé la violence ni la violence des
manifestations ni peut-être la violence
politique
le climat de violence politique existe
dans ce pays je pense que les
démocraties occidentales dans leur
ensemble vivent une crise de défiance et
que le vrai échec de même macron et que
sa promesse était de réenchanter en
quelque sorte justement en tout cas de
nous faire sortir collectivement de
cette crise de défiance très clairement
il n'y est pas parvenu
mais alors que la france vit son
quarante septième jour de grève contre
la réforme des retraites les internes en
médecine se sont mobilisés à l'appel des
syndicats
rassemblement aujourd'hui à paris place
du panthéon horaire hebdomadaire
conséquent repos de sécurité bafoués ou
encore choix de stages anxiogène et en
indications sont nombreuses des
précisions sur place avec estelle farges
quand
ouvert nous disent c'est une question
d'organisation c'est pas une question de
moyens ça suffit oui
la colère est là ce gouvernement est
minoritaire aujourd'hui il peut pas
s'appuyer sur la pseudo démocratie de
l'élection d' il ya maintenant presque
trois ans pour justifier tous ses
mauvais coups voilà aujourd'hui
l'hôpital public est à l'agonie
ça entraîne des morts voilà et je le dis
fortement ça entraîne des morts est
aujourd'hui monsieur macro madame busin
les députés qui ont voté la loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale qui
continuent à antraigues mais
financièrement l'hôpital is ils sont
responsables de ces morts de ces gens
qu'on pourrait sauver si on avait les
moyens d prendre en charge correctement
les protestations antigouvernementales
également en irak est les manifestants
relance la contestation pour demander
l'exécutif d'apporter des réponses à
leurs revendications
trois personnes sont mortes aujourd'hui
à bagdad selon les médecins depuis
octobre environ 460 personnes ont perdu
la vie françois xavier lambert c'est
devenu un rituel pour ces manifestants
le visage masqué drapeaux irakiens en
main ils continuent de se mobiliser au
milieu de pneus enflammés déposés sur
les grands axes des principales villes
d'irak
mais ces barricades de fortune n'évite
pas les affrontements avec la police
anti émeute
les forces de l'ordre multiplient les
jets de gaz lacrymogènes mais aussi les
tirs à balles réelles pour disperser les
protestataires
aujourd'hui nous bloquons les routes en
solidarité avec les populations de
naciria il a et bagdad
nous avons dit que nos manifestations
étaient pacifiques mais les policiers
nous ont tiré dessus
demain on brûlera plus sait on tira au
régime corrompu ne sous-estimé pas les
manifs et
les manifestants avaient fixé un
ultimatum au gouvernement pour répondre
à leurs demandes
un ultimatum qui expire ce lundi parmi
ces revendications des élections
anticipées
une réforme de la loi électorale la fin
de la corruption ou encore la
désignation d'un premier ministre
indépendant démissionnaire abdel mahdi
continue à diriger le pays alors que les
partis politiques ne s'entendent pas sur
un successeur à cette situation
politique incertaine s'ajoute un
contexte régional toujours explosif
après les récents événements entre les
etats-unis et l'iran de pays très
influent en irak un embrasement lié à la
mort du général iranien qasem soleimani
tués par un raid américain près de
l'aéroport de bagdad au début du mois
depuis octobre
les violences en irak ont coûté la vie à
près de 460 personnes et fait plus de 25
mille blessés
et pour françois constantine et docteur
en sciences politiques le gouvernement
irakiens cherchent à gagner du temps que
le gréement irakiens cherchent à gagner
du temps face à cette contestation sans
précédent qui est dans le pays
ensuite il faut savoir que les les même
si la tension entre iran etats unis
quelque peu retombée au moins de façon
momentanée les questions géopolitiques
les questions stratégiques ne sont pas
absents ce puissant on sait très bien
que dans les manifestations il ya
beaucoup de choses il ya en effet des
revendications aux primaires qui
explique l'importance des manifestations
qui sont d'ailleurs 34 ans
confessionnelle mais il ya également
dans une certaine mesure le jeu entre
l'iran jeu de l'iran et certains pôles
chiites irakiens qui prend forme dans
l'est dans sa tente de rendre aux
indications pour le moment on peut dire
qu'il n'y a pas de véritable
perspectives pour le gouvernement
irakien donc on s'interroge encore sur
les compromis qui peuvent rallumer tous
gouvernants formés sur investissement en
irak un gouvernement de compromis
les violences ce week-end à beyrouth
entre militants anti système et
policiers anti émeutes ont fait plus de
120 blessés les manifestants exigent
depuis trois mois le départ de la classe
politique qu'il juge corrompu et
inefficace
jordi demory le liban a connu ce
week-end le plus violent depuis le début
de la contestation le 17 octobre dernier
d'importants affrontements ont eu lieu
samedi et dimanche entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre à beyrouth
bilan plus de 520 blessés deux jours de
suite la police anti émeute a tiré des
balles en caoutchouc et des grenades
lacrymogènes à l'entrée d'une avenue
menant au parlement où étaient
rassemblés les contestataires depuis le
début du mouvement il ya trois mois la
colère n'a fait que croître
les manifestants fustige l'apathie des
dirigeants alors que la crise économique
s'aggrave il y à peu nous avons appris
que ce gouvernement s'est effondré
qu'ils n'ont pas réussi à s'entendre
c'est normal parce que les voleurs ne
peuvent pas s'entendre entre eux chacun
veut gagner un plus gros morceau au
profit du peuple appauvri
nous rejetons tout gouvernement qui
comprend des personnes de ces partis qui
nous ont volés nous continuerons de
manifester de bloquer les routes et nous
ne quitterons pas les rues tant que la
révolution n'aura pas triomphé obtenu ce
qu'elle veut en réaction à ce week-end
de violences le président libanais
michel aoun a convoqué ce lundi une
réunion de sécurité
parmi les présents les ministres de la
défense et de l'intérieur mais aussi des
hauts gradés des forces de la police et
de l'armée
l'objectif est de discuter des
développements sur le plan sécuritaire
et des mesures à prendre pour préserver
la stabilité et le calme
de son côté la france est dit préoccupé
par ces violences et souligne l'urgence
de la formation d'un nouveau
gouvernement dans la grave crise
économique et sociale que traverse le
liban et compte tenu des violences
récentes l'urgence et qu'un nouveau
gouvernement met en oeuvre
ensemble crédible de réformes pour
répondre aux attentes exprimées par les
libanais depuis plus de trois mois
la france entend comme toujours se tenir
aux côtés du peuple libanais l'impasse
politique s'ajoute à la crise depuis la
démission fin octobre du premier
ministre saad hariri hassan diab désigné
comme son successeur le 19 décembre n'a
toujours pas formé son équipe
les tractations avec les grands partis
traîne chaque faction cherchant à
garantir sa représentation au sein de la
future équipe
dans la rue les manifestants réclament
inlassablement un gouvernement de
technocrates indépendants de l'actuelle
classe dirigeante quasi inchangé depuis
des décennies et de son côté les ong
human right watch au moyen-orient des
noms je suis l'impunité et des amis
policiers lors des violents
affrontements du week-end
écoutez il n'y avait aucune
justification pour le recours brutal à
la force par la police anti-émeute
libanaise contre des manifestants
largement pacifiques dans le centre
ville de beyrouth le 18 janvier
la police anti émeute a montré un mépris
flagrant matière de droits de l'homme en
tirant des cartouches de gaz lacrymogène
sur la tête des manifestants et des
balles en caoutchouc dans les yeux en
attaquant les personnes dans des
hôpitaux et une mosquée les événements
de la nuit dernière ont montré qu'il
était urgent que les autorités mettent
fin à cette culture d'impunité pour les
abus de la police et pour aulas attache
analyste politique spécialiste du
moyen-orient la réponse sécuritaire du
gouvernement n'est pas une solution pour
apaiser la colère la révolution at ans
sont plus une réponse
aux demandes de réformes de réformes
sérieuses à un gouvernement qui
représente le peuple et ses droits on ne
parle plus de deux demandes de topics
nous demandons les droits du peuple et
c'est pas du tout les le la réponse
qu'on attendait du président de la
république malheureusement l'iran menace
de se retirer du traité sur la non
prolifération des armes nucléaires
annonce aujourd'hui en réponse au
déclenchement par les européens d'un
mécanisme de règlement des différends
contre téhéran est le chef de la
diplomatie iranienne
jawad arrive dénonce l'absence de base
légale ce processus permet au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies de rétablir
les sanctions évité grâce à l'accord sur
le nucléaire traité dont washington
s'est retiré en mai 2010huit paris
berlin et londres disent rester engagés
au sein de ce texte
téhéran les accuse dynaction un côté la
porte parole du ministère des affaires
étrangères si ces discussions se
poursuivent l'iran prépare une mesure
finale et même plus efficace dont je ne
connais pas les détails pour le moment
différentes options pour l'iran sont sur
la table et elles seront annoncées
si nous parvenons à un consensus poutine
a soumis ce lundi au parlement un
ensemble d'amendements constitutionnels
le président russe a présenté les
changements proposés dans son discours
sur l'état de la nation
destinée à renforcer le rôle du
parlement et à consolider la démocratie
et chambre basse a reçu un projet de loi
sur les propositions constitutionnelles
du kremlin et a rapidement programme est
la première des trois lectures requises
pour jeudi
c'est très forme impliquera le transfert
de plus de pouvoir aux citoyens de notre
pays afin qu'ils puissent participer
plus efficacement au gouvernement en
s'attaquant aux problèmes auxquels notre
pays est confronté
en même temps le pouvoir présidentiel
reste fort basé sur les questions liées
à l'évaluation des activités des
fonctionnaires fédéraux du premier
ministre des responsables régionaux et
sur la possibilité de les révoquer ce
pays pour la libye les représentants
internationaux réunis hier à berlin
s'accordent sur une déclaration commune
avec deux points majeurs la fin de
l'ingérence étrangère et le respect de
l'embargo sur les livraisons d'armes
théo combes avec emilie goût gâcher cet
élevage
une deuxième série voilà ce que veulent
éviter les parties prenantes du dossier
libye
les dirigeants des principaux pays
concernés par ce conflit ce sont
accordés sur un communiqué final mais
les tractations devraient se poursuivre
cette semaine selon l'hôte de cette
conférence le ministre allemand des
affaires étrangères
nous avons atteint notre objectif à la
conférence de berlin sur la libye hier
hier avec les deux parties à berlin nous
avons personnaliser la réunion 10 du
format 5 + 5
l envoyé spécial des nations unies
ghassan salamé va tenir une réunion
officielle cette semaine pour s'assurer
que le cessez-le-feu peut se transformer
en armistice le but est non seulement
d'appeler un cessez le feu permanent en
libye mais aussi de mettre fin aux
interférences étrangères dans le pays le
secrétaire général des nations unies
antonio goûter res a insisté sur ce
point tous les participants se sont
engagés à s'abstenir de toute ingérence
dans le conflit armé ou les affaires
intérieures de la libye
cela fait partie des conclusions et bien
entendu elles doivent être respectées
ainsi que l'appel à faire taire les
armes à feu avec la fin de toute
hostilité militaire pour sa part le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov a regretté l'absence de
discussions directes entre les deux
camps rivaux libyen mais il a tenu à
saluer le pas en avant effectué pour
stabiliser une trêve fragile le cessez
le feu est entré en vigueur le 12
janvier à l'initiative de la russie et
de la turquie
aujourd'hui on a constaté qu'il était
généralement respecté
bien que des violations aient lieu des
deux côtés
enfin les 11 participants ont appelé le
conseil de sécurité a imposé des
sanctions à ceux qui violeraient les
dispositions du cessez le feu est la
libye entre autres à l'ordre du jour du
conseil des affaires étrangères
aujourd'hui à bruxelles écoutez à ce
propos le chef de la diplomatie
européenne l'espagnol josep borrell
il y a plusieurs possibilités mais vous
savez qu'un cessez-le-feu existe que
quelqu'un sans nous qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas dire que c'est un cessez le feu
puis les billets le contrôle des armes
le contrôle de l'embargo
il y a plusieurs possibilités et les
ministres devront décider de ce qu'il
faut faire pour aider à mettre en oeuvre
les accords d'hier pays réunis hier à
berlin la fin de toute ingérence morad
el hattab dénonce les divers ingérence
en libye depuis le début du conflit des
spécialistes de ce pays à hauteur de
saïf al islam kadhafi un rêve d'avenir
pour la libye aux éditions eric bonnet
l'interférence l adieu depuis le départ
dès 2011
la france a mis en place les intégristes
au pouvoir par le biais de monsieur
bellaciao c'est un combattant d'al qaïda
puis gouverneur de tripoli se disant
combattants de la liberté
et depuis ben nous avons deux
gouvernements 1 à tripoli
monsieur sa rage qui se déclarent une
liste du gouvernement libyen alors qu'il
n'a même pas été reconnus par la chambre
des représentants libyenne ni par le
conseil général libyen mais selon les
accords de red hat supervisés par l'onu
et puis haftar qui s'autoproclament
maréchal et qui effectivement avait fait
des élections à tout brook
donc on a comme ça une partition du pays
et où étrangement des pays autres essais
chacun de tirer la couverture à soi
par rapport à des intérêts purement
liées aux matières premières
kuala lumpur envoie 150 conteneurs de
déchets illégaux vers leurs capitales
occidentales concernées paris londres ou
encore washington est malaisie refuse de
devenir je cite la décharge des pays
développés florian lambert
la malaisie capitale mondiale du déchet
150 conteneurs de déchets plastiques
illégaux ont été renvoyés de malaisie
vers leur pays d'origine
43 concerne la france les autorités de
ce pays d'asie du sud est ont affirmé
qu'elles ne voulaient pas que leur
territoire devienne une décharge pour
les pays développés
mais la ministre malaisienne de
l'environnement liés au be in souhaite
collaborer avec les pays concernés pour
régler ce conflit notamment les états
unis à ce jour le gouvernement de la
malaisie a renvoyé 150 conteneurs de
plastique des déchets plastiques
illégaux contenant quelque 3700 37
tonnes grâce à notre inspection dans les
ports et aux données du département
royal des douanes malaisienne la plupart
des conteneurs sont exportés des pays
développés notamment la france le
royaume-uni les etats-unis et le canada
l'espagne et le japon
celui qui doit être renvoyée vient des
états unis
nous en avons encore 60 sur son disque
qui viennent des états unis
nous continuerons donc à travailler avec
le gouvernement américain les organismes
locaux compétents aux états unis pour
nous assurer que nous les renverrons le
marché mondial du recyclage a connu un
bouleversement majeur depuis la décision
en 2018 de la chine de cesser
l'importation de déchets plastiques
de nombreuses entreprises chinoises de
recyclage ont été délocalisée en
malaisie entraînant un afflux de déchets
souvent est légal plusieurs pays d'asie
du sud-est ont pratiqué la même
politique ces derniers mois
l'indonésie a également expédié
plusieurs centaines de conteneurs vers
leur pays d'origine
en juin dernier le canada avait rapatrié
plusieurs tonnes de déchets entreposés
aux philippines durant plusieurs années
un contentieux qui avait provoqué une
longue crise diplomatique entre les deux
pays
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité ce sera demain 7h du matin
heure française excellent de fin de nuit
à tous
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous cet
écho politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent
vous n en soit vient des lignes ans